He freaks what's going on.
Party people were back.
Uh,
I've been,
um,
I've been busy squash and so I haven't had time to podcasts and I'm out there
searching for bigfoot.
What are you doing,
Bryan?
You're not,
you're not answering the big foot question.
Just sitting here doing podcasts.
I've already made it
come out there for the people.
Son.
I'm out there steady squashing.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
Squarespace.
Squarespace is one of our newest and favorite sponsors.
I don't really have any favorites,
but I really enjoy this one.
I really like it.
I like everything about it.
What it is is a website that allows you to very easily create your own website.
There's templates that you can use.
There's various images that you can upload and you can make a really cool
looking website including setting up a store.
You can set up an online store super easy.
It's,
it's ridiculous how easy it is and it's cool and it's fun.
You can also try it out.
You can go there and set up a website and not even have to use your credit card.
You just,
uh,
try it out.
Hold on.
Let me just pull this up.
I gotta
yeah,
it's cool cause they just have all these,
does that like you could put together a website and almost like within five
minutes.
Well you have,
you know,
I couldn't,
it would take me a lot longer than it would take you but,
but uh,
Brian can whip through one of those fucking things and it's um,
it's,
I love the fact that there's someone figure that out cause it used to be like so
daunting.
The idea of creating a website was terrifying.
I'm like,
what am I going to do with this?
This is,
this makes it super easy.
It makes,
it's really intuitive and it works on everything.
It works on a cell phone,
it works in your iPad or android tablet.
It works on every phone.
It works on every browser.
It's just,
they,
they've got it down and it didn't use to be down.
It used to be like really difficult to get a website.
But now almost anybody can do their own.
And if you go to squarespace.com forward slash Joe,
you can try it out,
no credit card necessary.
But if you would decide to purchase it,
you use the offer code,
excuse me,
use the offer code Joe Five,
just Joe and the number five,
all one word.
And then you will save 10% off a first purchase,
a new accounts including monthly and annual plans.
So that's squarespace.com forward slash Joe and the offer code is Joe and the
number three,
excuse me,
five show the number five.
Don't use Joe the number three.
You'll confuse the fuck out of people.
And they'll think,
man,
someone's just really stuck on those old march podcasts
were also brought to you by Tang.
Um,
if you,
uh,
have heard of Tim before,
if you've heard of us talk about on a podcast,
one of the things that makes me so happy is when I run into people and they tell
me that something that we're advertising in the podcast is exactly as promised.
And,
uh,
that's one thing that I keep hearing about ting.
It's,
it's a,
it's a really good cell phone service.
It uses a sprint backbone,
but it's set up to be a lot cheaper than most cell phone plans.
And it's set up in a really cool ethical way,
including if you,
if you don't use the minutes that you signed up for,
they knock you down to the next level and credit you at your next bill.
They,
they literally give you credit for anew service.
I mean,
nobody does that.
They,
they don't use,
usually if you don't use your service,
they're like tough shit.
That's what you,
you offered,
that's what you bought.
That was your,
your contract was a hundred minutes a month or whenever the hell it is.
See,
I love fucking team.
They're great.
It's great.
And,
and when we were in Vancouver for 24 hours,
I use both of my,
uh,
cell phones,
one from at t and t and one from a Tang.
And I just got the bill to find out how much my overages were for,
you know,
using international air,
uh,
eight and t because I was on a shitty day to plan and I said I was just being
stupid.
Uh,
it was 200 and like $70 or something like that.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
For one hour for one day.
So we're the king,
which I used a lot actually because,
uh,
it had better service there.
Um,
$17.
Wow.
That's insane.
First of all,
the tin can make it that cheap,
but it's also insane that 18 tickets send you a bill that high.
It's just so,
it's so weird that you'd go over to Canada and all of a sudden the same rules
don't apply.
It's like three hours away.
Right.
It takes is three.
It takes us five to get to New York.
It's like,
it doesn't make any sense.
It's so stupid.
I'm so tired of countries and it's really fucking stupid.
Right.
Just at and t even doing that,
cause they know there's people like me that wouldn't cause they watch.
What they want you to do is they want you to call them,
get on a international calling plan or a data plan,
choose which one you want and then it would probably be cheaper.
Uh,
but what they're doing,
it's like,
hey,
you didn't call us so we're just going to fuck you.
You know?
I mean we're like tanks.
Just like,
hey man,
strong words,
whatever words,
you know,
they don't need to teach,
just misunderstood.
They also don't charge you for teetering either,
which is another thing.
It's called tethering.
Tethering either.
It's either one of those that you don't really say that much,
but you see written down a lot.
Yeah.
It's like something else,
like role,
like some people say rolfing when it's like,
no,
just rolfing,
the massage thing.
No,
no,
no.
When you're like rolling on the floor laughing.
Oh Aro yeah.
Roll on the floor.
Laughing my ass off.
Yeah.
So let's say that I was like,
what?
I've never heard that.
But people would just spell it out.
Yeah,
those people.
But yeah,
like like they don't charge you for a tethering so like that,
which is you shouldn't have to pay for anyways.
What?
You have to have a button,
that software button,
it turns on and off.
That's why you have to pay for it.
Yeah.
You have the same amount of data.
What do you care if I use it off my phone or my laptop?
Right.
I'm on,
I have the phone I bought.
This is my phones.
It's not wearing out the phone,
you know it's not doing,
there's no reason.
But you know with the Tang they give it to you for free,
which is how it should be.
Yeah.
It was a gift free voicemail and stuff.
It comes with free stuff.
It's ethical company
and it's,
it's a,
it's a fair company and they have great phones.
They have the coolest android phones,
including the Samsung Galaxy note too,
which is that big giant thing.
That's the one that you,
I mean you really read websites on it,
take pictures with it.
You can watch movies on it and want looking at your photos on it as a completely
different experience than a smaller phone.
You know,
the people that try it,
it's,
it's a pain in the ass for people to get used to,
but once they try it and they get used to that giant screen,
you don't ever want to go back to a little tiny babies Christmas.
Oh,
they have the galaxy s four.
Now.
I want it.
Yeah,
it's amazing the,
uh,
the technology that's available today,
but you don't,
the point is you don't have to lose technology to use the tink service.
It's a,
it's cheap.
It's awesome.
And if you go to rogan.ting.com,
you will save 25 bucks off of either one of your,
uh,
new cell phones or,
or the service.
So go and check it out.
You're freaks.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com,
um,
if you,
uh,
have never been on it.com,
it's a,
the best way to describe it as a,
it's a human performance website.
And Damn,
I tarted doing commercials about this.
It's impossible to think of new things to say about art if you've never heard of
it before though.
Uh,
it's a company that we sounded like kettle bells and battle ropes and vitamins
and it's all like stuff that is uh,
designed to help human performance.
Whether it's your endurance with shroom tech sport or whether it's,
you know,
physical strength with things like battle ropes or maces.
And I know at Macy's and clubs they look like weapons but they're not weapons.
Okay.
They're not,
they're just exercise equipment and it's exercise equipment that mimics the use
of weapons because believe it or not,
like those dudes had to like swing swords of you.
You have to live in game of Thrones time.
You have to be strong as shit man to be able to swing a big giant piece of
metal.
And when you not advocating any sword use,
but I'm saying when you use something like that,
like a steel mace or a steel club using these a weapon like pieces of exercise
equipment,
it actually makes you use your body as one whole unit and it improves your
athletic performance.
And in other areas,
like if you,
if you have a sport that you do or if it's a martial arts thing,
the uh,
the strength and fitness that you can get from a good kettlebell workout or a
mace workout,
it really does.
Uh,
do you,
uh,
some great benefits.
So go and check it out.
Use the Code Dean Brogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
That's O,
n n I t.
Alex Gray is here.
You dirty freaks.
So strap in,
open up your third eye,
get your shit together
and away we go.
Joe Rogan podcast.
[inaudible] Jesus Louisa's.
What are we doing here?
And we sent an email,
the person,
I'll,
I'll explain it to the person on the podcast is today one of my favorite artists
and the history of the universe.
How about that?
How about,
uh,
there's a small handful of people that I would have liked to have meet more than
you.
And so,
uh,
having you on the podcast the first time was a true honor and a treat and uh,
it's a,
it's just cool to be in contact with you.
I think you are a,
you represent,
represent representative,
very positive and a very unusual force in the world of art and then the world of
consciousness as well.
You know,
your,
your artwork is so uh,
moving and so representative of the psychedelic state that it actually has like
an effect on people.
You know,
I think your artwork is probably like some of the,
the most accurate psychedelic artwork I've ever seen and I can't tell you how
many people I've been with that have seen your artwork or seeing one of your
pieces for the first time and just went fuck.
You know,
like that's like the,
the,
the usual reaction when they see one of your crazier pieces.
Like,
uh,
the one that's like the one that I always think of when I think of you as these
three faces,
they look like Egyptian sort of pharaoh type faces and they're all three.
One is facing forward and two on the sides and it just seems like a DMT trip.
It seems like you're tripping when you're watching it.
Right?
Yeah.
It's an attempt to point to that the embeddedness that we are in time,
the flow of time,
and yet there is always a timeless being that,
uh,
we also are the witness of that,
um,
being in time.
Why is it so terrifying?
Because we are in time and there's a countdown,
you know,
there's a,
where none of us get out alive,
et Cetera,
et Cetera to do,
do,
do.
Yeah.
Hey Ray.
Hey,
we love you.
Yeah.
Mm.
Just
past.
Um,
it's,
um,
it really is a weird thing though to see it so clearly captured in artwork and
it's one of the weirdest things that people point to when they point to a either
ancient religious art or,
you know,
just various,
uh,
things that were,
it's hard to find you,
uh,
evidence of psychedelic use.
And there are like,
they didn't,
it's,
it's hard to find moments where they cat like this is one is hard.
There's no,
there was none,
nothing like this that came out of the old world.
And it's fascinating to me because if,
you know,
Mckenna was right with this height be of the stoned ape theory,
and you know,
that mushrooms probably shaped human culture.
It's like,
clearly there were long periods of time probably where people weren't getting
that.
Uh,
but there was a,
a continual evolution of the,
um,
uh,
ability to express,
the dimensions of the world and of the imagine a world.
And you can see it from cave aren't,
which they now believe that even the neanderthal may have had a early form of
cave art.
So it wasn't just the Cro Max,
you know,
and,
and the,
uh,
but,
we may have had ancestors who were also aren't us.
Yeah.
It's the cave art is one of the weirder things about ancient man.
If you've seen the Werner Herzog documentary about,
uh,
the ancient cave art,
I believe is in France.
Is that where it was?
Yeah.
What is it called?
Cave of dreams?
Yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
I actually didn't see it and I've heard all about it and I really want to,
you know,
and I haven't yet,
so,
oh,
it's one of those things.
Yeah.
Did you love it?
I only got a chain.
I was,
I was running out the door when it was on,
so I only got a chance to see it for about an hour.
But it was fascinating just the idea that they were painting these incredible
things just close to 30,000 years ago,
40,000 years ago,
something crazy like that at this is some of the oldest stuff.
Just this is the idea that you're looking at something that someone 40,000 years
ago drew,
it seems so insane,
but it also seems like a blip.
Really stop and think about 43,000 years to go from that to us from,
from drawing on rocks as being,
you know,
your,
your main form of expression and like drawing buffalo to 40,000 years later,
taking pictures of yourself and sending them to people on the other side of the
planet.
So it's not that far.
30,000 years is like really quick to do that.
Jill.
Making pictures.
Yeah.
And making pictures is becoming an even more important,
uh,
part of communication.
What do you think that it that is that feeling that you get when you see a piece
of art?
When you see something beautiful,
when you see something that even if it's the same feeling,
for me it's almost exactly the same thing.
When I see nature,
a beautiful scene in nature as I see a beautiful human creation.
So that seems to have no differentiation.
And in my imagination,
when I see like a beautiful sunset or a beautiful forest,
you know,
in the mountains in a lake and that,
that perfect classic scene,
or if I see a beautiful painting or a beautiful piece of art,
it's the same thing.
It gives you that,
wow.
That that's what we're looking for all the time.
This also expression,
we
crave it.
I think it's actually something that,
um,
human beings,
you know,
either secretly or not so secretly crave and,
uh,
looking at other people and in,
and in finding it,
uh,
in their lives.
I kind of think that's a,
that's almost an aesthetic,
uh,
and spiritual quest in itself to find the beauty in the moment in every moment
is actually a,
uh,
quite a,
um,
profound,
uh,
state to be.
And,
you know,
yeah.
It's just such a strange thing to be able to do.
You know,
if you looked at it out,
if you were outside of human culture and you said,
what are they doing there?
They're creating beautiful things and they'll look at it and get a positive
feeling from it.
Huh?
Like that image serves no other function other than the express themselves.
No,
they can't eat it.
They can't,
they can't,
they don't make houses out of it.
They're just,
just make it and they look at it and stare at it and they think it's awesome.
Well,
you know,
in the back of the dollar bill,
they have that some masonic looking at pyramid with the eye and the triangle
floating above.
And so it's an unfinished pyramid.
And I've heard it interpreted as the individual or the nation is incomplete
without guidance,
by higher vision.
And so the,
uh,
aspiration for a higher vision is what distinguishes may be a sacred art and,
a psychedelic aren't that aims at a universal kind of mystical visionary
experience and uh,
just kind of fantasy art at,
cause I think that,
uh,
with the widespread use of psychedelics,
so many people have seen these realms that that's why that it causes a bit of a,
when people see it,
sometimes it's because they've seen it inside themselves,
but maybe not outside of themselves.
Yeah.
It's almost like a,
like a familiar image.
Like even though it's so bizarrely outrageous and you just to like,
wow,
what have I seen?
I seen this God damn thing before.
I'm like,
what is it about?
Especially that one with the three heads,
but that one really knocked my socks off.
Yeah.
You're gonna make a whole building like that,
man.
That's what the [inaudible] is.
That's tosh about.
I can't take that with,
well,
it's all the way around.
I know 20 foot heads.
It's going to be the coolest place on the planet earth.
That is,
that is without a doubt going to be the coolest building on the planet earth.
There's nothing cooler than that.
You,
you,
you made an Alex Gray building
and an Allison gray building.
Yeah,
it's exactly,
this is her writing cred language that uh,
the thing that binds the building
that looks great out of a piece of the wreckage from Roswell.
That's what I would expect that writing to come from.
That looks awesome.
If human language that's looks like some,
like something,
someone would get tattooed on them,
they wouldn't even know what it meant.
It just looks so cool.
Watch.
I thought you could,
you know,
if you had like one head here and then,
and then it could,
it could go completely around the body.
Oh,
someone will do that and now that you just suggested someone will definitely do
that.
Or You could make a tee shirt march Sunday.
Yeah.
That's,
maybe that's a good mood.
Yeah.
Well,
are you going to sell t shirts for me?
People would love to have this t shirt.
I guarantee you.
Well,
you know,
there's an fee on a t shirt that we're going to be working on.
We should explain to people what NCR is.
If they didn't listen to the first podcast,
you are built,
you have essentially,
you've created your own religion.
You'll,
like,
everybody has always said that.
Wouldn't it be amazing if somebody created a religion that,
uh,
actually wasn't based on anything ancient or based on trying to get your money,
but based on the true principles of love and the word that you like to use all
the time,
God,
you know,
you want to take that word back.
You're going to try to take that word back from the Bible bangers.
But,
um,
it's,
uh,
it's a kind of a,
an amazing thing to do and know because I know you and I know like what you're
about.
You're not doing this for any nefarious reasons.
You're doing it for the perfect reasons.
And that's really rare where someone has a voice and the,
they choose to just go all in like that.
You've created a religion,
man.
Well,
it's,
uh,
an orientation toward the spiritual and yes,
legitimately essay.
Uh,
religion,
because that's a,
within the,
um,
embrace of the,
uh,
expanding and evolving spirit of humanity.
We have to start thinking as a planetary civilization.
And the Internet has helped us all to form an image of a networked,
kind of a distributed intelligence that goes all around the world.
And that's happened before people even realized it.
It's already crept up on people.
Exactly.
It's,
it's now kind of the ocean in which we swim.
But by making note of it,
uh,
we can,
we notice it,
you know,
and,
uh,
so
by the power of that community that,
uh,
connect virtually with each other,
the Kickstarter campaign for the building events,
the Aan has been going strongly and just,
uh,
creeping upward every day.
And,
uh,
just today,
like broke the hundred thousand,
uh,
mark and,
we're going toward 125 and we've got about nine days left.
So where,
how do they get to this if people want to contribute to this Kickstarter?
Well,
they can go to kickstarter.com [inaudible] and,
uh,
go and theone.
Where do they put that in the search?
I just,
I just googled Alex.
There you go.
Kickstarter.
Oh,
there.
Okay.
Just Google that.
Google.
Alex grey.
Kickstarter.
Yeah.
So,
um,
and you were,
what you're doing is essentially you're building a temple.
You're building a work of art that it really,
it's kind of fascinating because if a lot of people who believed that
psychedelic drugs are at the heart of almost all religions and psychedelic
experience and psychedelic imagery,
um,
in,
in ancient religious artwork where,
you know,
there's the things that represent mushrooms and shapes that are mushrooms,
these,
um,
incredible buildings that have been built for religion.
I mean,
if you really stop and think about some of the greatest architectural
achievements,
it's been like the most beautiful ones have been the ones that were created for
religions.
It's like they,
you know,
and it wanting in whatever part of what they are that is good,
wanting to achieve some higher level.
They've done it with their art,
with the,
the architecture,
with you.
Look at some of the ancient Roman architecture that's dedicated to the Catholic
church.
It's staggering stuff outside of the creepiness of the Catholic Church,
which is undeniable.
And I came from it,
did the artwork,
the architectural artwork is just masterful.
It's stunning.
It's like nothing else,
you know,
Michelangelo.
Yeah.
There you go.
You know,
the greatest of all geniuses,
artistic,
uh,
you know,
architectural and uh,
as paintings and sculptures.
She amazing that any of those guys tripped.
Well,
you know,
he was a neoplatonist and uh,
does that mean well that means he was an idealist and that he was,
uh,
he had just become familiar with the,
um,
we're looking at an image Socrates.
That is insane.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
So keep going.
Yeah,
exactly.
So you spun around a little bit and got to see the,
the all the heads and it's cool.
That is amazing.
And uh,
so all of these,
uh,
works,
you're going to be on view in the,
uh,
within Antionne
did,
you could change people's lives just with these pictures.
There's so trippy.
They make you like that one right there that makes you go what is real and
what's not real.
That thinks too freaky.
Yeah.
And what is reality?
Why is that image so familiar?
Cause we aren't connected with everything.
You know.
I mean all look,
all the mistake,
uh,
traditions talk about there's only one of us,
you know,
all of them.
Yeah.
And so that,
that's the foundation of the understanding,
uh,
is uh,
a sense of oneness.
And uh,
so the idea of the network itself and uh,
have,
uh,
a planetary,
a sense of humanity is I think wearing away the a nationhood and nation state,
uh,
ideal,
toward,
uh,
um,
hopeful and democratic,
but we'll struggle for some time.
Was that,
yeah,
I think it's a possibility.
You know,
I have hope for people.
I really do.
I,
and I think the Internet is what gives me the most hope because I think that
the,
it's the first time people who have ever had a straight pipe to the world.
Everybody has a straight pipe to everybody else and information is settling and
people are starting to understand that they are a greater understanding of what
constitutes a happy life and how to achieve happiness and how,
how to surround yourself with positive people and how to,
you know,
how to express yourself in a healthy way.
And that's all the Internet.
The Internet has given people,
I think,
a way better understanding of,
of life itself than any generation has ever had before.
And so to have this and to create it with
the Internet,
it's kind of,
it's kind of perfect.
It's kind of beautiful.
Yeah.
Like a crowdsourcing sacred space that is a,
uh,
it could only happen,
today
with the friends.
Well,
because of people like you though,
they're doing things like that.
That's one of the reasons why I have faith.
It's one of the reasons why I think that.
I know a lot of people gravitate towards your stuff.
A lot of people gravitate towards your words and they gravitate towards your
artwork.
And I think that gives me hope that I think that there's a,
there's people that are trying to put themselves on a,
on a good frequency,
and there's people that are not just people that had just ended.
I have billing negative.
I'll never let it go,
but,
but they're there.
That phase of the chemical,
a journey of healing maybe,
uh,
you know,
it's like,
uh,
I don't know.
It's so I think,
uh,
there's a spectrum for sure.
There's a spectrum of fortune luck,
the luck of the draw of where you were born,
who you were associated with.
Oh my God,
your family.
There's a,
that's an undeniable luck of the draw.
You know,
I think every day I grew up with the people I up with.
I got really lucky with my parents.
They were really nice.
You know,
that's not the case with everybody and that's luck.
So well,
it's almost,
he can't make,
you know,
some people are just there.
They're born into such a massive deficits.
I got a few years,
uh,
on your,
I think,
and,
uh,
sh I recently ran about,
I Schopenhauer essay where he talks about,
uh,
they,
how almost everyone at a certain age,
it looks back on their life and even events that appeared random,
uh,
during the,
their occurrence,
uh,
appeared to have been faded and,
took them in a particular direction and that really had become very important
for them.
And so it's curious that,
uh,
because I mean,
it was like not with meeting and that was a,
it was like not with taking LSD.
Uh,
it was,
um,
you know,
their momentous and a life changing kind of,
uh,
occurrences and they can turn you from a,
a sour,
uh,
and a suicidal person to a person that has a love for life and a,
a commitment to trying to,
um,
uh,
leave the most,
Eh,
the gift that you've been,
uh,
sort of,
requested to,
uh,
to perform,
you know,
the service you've been asked to prove.
What do you mean by that?
Well,
end theone,
uh,
is a sanctuary,
a visionary aren't,
and that's always been our aspiration is to provide a more on a more permanent
basis.
Of course,
that's still an aspiration at this point,
but,
uh,
that we did acquire the land of 40 Acre property.
And,
uh,
we,
do have permission now after,
um,
over a couple of years of negotiation and preparation of site plan and getting a
site plan approval from the town,
we now have the permission to build,
uh,
and theone.
And,
uh,
it is,
and the Kickstarter has been a way of connecting with this net of beings that
have,
uh,
you know,
also taken on the imagining of it with us and the financing of it.
Where do you see this going?
Do you see this becoming a n theone like once,
once the NC on its built would have a bunch of people want to like move the
property.
Would you,
would you consider like you have a guest house?
Yes,
we have a guest house to receive them and that is open now for business and a
that we've been hosting a numerous people that come and stay there already and
we were open on a more weekly basis now.
Uh,
and,
but it's,
it's just a beautiful time of the year.
It's,
and uh,
there's wisdom trails.
You can walk around and there's some art in the House and the cosmic Christ is
there.
How far in is the construction process?
Well,
we have done reinforcing of the carriage house around which this building is
going to be.
The heads are going to be clad and folks that are just listening on Itunes,
what Alex's,
uh,
you could see it if you go to Alex,
Alex grey.com.
So if you go to Alex Gray,
g r e y a.com and go look at some of the images of,
it's really,
it's,
it's the weirdest,
craziest,
coolest looking building I've ever seen in my life.
And if you,
you do completely build it this way,
it's really going to be one of the coolest things on earth.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a building that's a work of art and it's a stunning work of art.
Have these bad ass.
It's very interesting because it,
it makes a,
I,
um,
statement and I,
I see it as within a lineage of the development of different kinds of sacred
architecture and just one other little but on that tree.
But,
uh,
it's attempting to point to the underlying
unity of the quest for wisdom and compassion and all the different religious
quests and that they have,
they share,
uh,
also in common,
the angel of the,
of creative expression,
which is the imagination.
And,
uh,
all world religions were born in the creative imagination.
It with the visionary mystical experience.
Um,
you know,
there was the,
uh,
the founding of,
Islam on the journey of,
uh,
of a Mohammed to the seventh heaven.
And he encounters many a visionary kinds of dimensions on the way and,
um,
and you know,
receives his wisdom.
And you know,
you have Mary receiving an angel.
You know,
you have Moses talking to a burning Bush.
All of these are visionary,
mystical experiences.
And,
uh,
there are the foundations of many of the world religions.
Mara is dispelled in the visionary experience,
uh,
with the Buddha.
The,
the soldiers,
uh,
they butted turns the arrows into flowers.
These are all kinds of a visionary,
mystical,
um,
contact with an infinite intermediate realm between the physical material world
and the transcendental world and all the really a mystical
traditions have them.
And we just kind of lost track of him except now we've recovered them through
psychedelics.
Do you think that that was the heart of,
you feel like that was the heart of all organized religion that originally it
was sort of a psychedelic experience or mystical of them or experience.
So it could have been like yoga or couldn't Delaney or something like that.
It can happen on the Nache and it,
and it has a for many,
but for some fasting and uh,
there are numerous kinds of,
um,
Boston tech austerities and things like that.
Uh,
that could have been a natural part of life.
Yes.
I haven't been eating for three days.
Uh,
but the water is a little tasting funny and uh,
and Lo and behold,
there's a vision and an angel appears
would say,
Hey,
yeah,
you're about to die.
Hallucinating.
Yeah.
Or just not worth the s and,
and dob.
Okay.
Soon so you can go to the edge and see
the other world as well.
And that,
you know,
can be valid as well.
But,
uh,
yeah,
these people,
one of the weird things about psychedelics is people always,
even if it was one of the most profound experiences ever,
and one the most amazing experiences ever,
people will tell you,
yeah,
but it was just your mind playing tricks on you.
Like it doesn't matter and you can go okay.
But it's whether it was,
whether I really did travel to another dimension and communicate with infinite
beings that were made out of love and understanding who told me the secret to
life is positive energy and positive.
Even if it was just my imagination,
I still experienced it.
I experienced it as if it was real.
So whether it was real or whether it wasn't real,
I can the exact same result.
Something happened that was unbelievably incredible.
It took me to some place that was infinitely beautiful and then something
happened to me.
Like either that happened or it didn't happen.
Well definitely happened.
It doesn't matter if it was imaginary.
It doesn't matter if it was only inside my head.
The whole world comes out of the inside of your head.
The,
when were kids.
I remember when I was a kid,
they would say like,
ah,
he's got such an imagination.
This one,
it was talking about kids that were liars.
You know?
That's how people treated the imagination and the kids would just fibbers you
know,
because that's imagination to some people.
You know,
some people they didn't think it was something to be encouraged,
but it's really where everything comes from.
And that's the weirdest thing about it is the imagination conjures up an idea,
which becomes a,
it conjures up an idea which becomes an airplane.
It all comes from the imagination.
Whether it's artistic,
whether it's a song,
whether it's a joke that's,
it's the weirdest thing ever.
And everybody wants to pretend that it's so normal and so normally just thinking
shit up out of the middle of fucking nowhere and creating nuclear power.
You know,
what did you do it?
You sat down and what,
you wrote some stuff on some,
a pad and then you figured it out.
Where's this all coming from?
Where's the idea to even do that coming from?
Where's the idea that some,
some guy wants to be like a fucking bird and put wings on and figure out how to
fly.
And he eventually figures it out.
And now we just travel all over the world and we don't think anything of it.
I mean,
the imagination is crazy.
The imagination has done some amazing things for human beings in this world.
And yet we still don't give her the credit it deserves.
It's a,
it was kind of shocking,
you know,
imagination.
It's like the most underrated thing of all time.
And yet it's the foundation of our advancement in evolution,
which news to work hard.
I don't have a fucking imagination sitting there,
seen some shit that's not there.
All right.
Well I think that that's the other thing that the,
um,
visionary experience with psychedelic sties is it convinces people of the
existence of the realms.
And,
uh,
if a,
you know,
suddenly find themselves in the DMT space,
it's like very unsettling perhaps.
Uh,
but then at least you can see that there is,
there is a,
there,
there is an infinite,
they're there.
And,
uh,
so this inner consciousness experience that,
the,
uh,
the one self is having through us,
is something I'm just fascinated by it.
I'm fascinated by how the mystics get at the one,
do you think?
No.
Listen,
this has always been a very,
a,
a strange one amongst the mushroom kind of sewers world.
Um,
some believe that in consuming that life form,
which is really closer to animal than it is to plant,
right?
Yes.
And consuming that mushroom,
what you're doing is that's how it communicates with you.
That's right.
And then these visions that you're getting,
this information that you're getting just almost downloaded to you in a way that
you can't understand or even comprehend.
Most of it I always described,
tried to remember what you're learning on mushrooms,
like trying to grab fish in a river.
Like,
ah,
I can't fucking gravity thing.
I can't hold onto it.
It's just too crazy.
I'm seeing too much.
I'm trying to calm down,
but I'm saying too much.
And it's,
and then you've sort of go,
oh,
okay.
This is where everything comes from,
comes from this crazy place.
Yeah.
That endless imagination and,
uh,
in flowing streams just like that.
And most of the big ones get away.
Yeah.
And then,
and then,
and then a few are just life altering and like the thing that really welded
Allison and I together,
uh,
because,
you know,
it was my first acid trip in her apartment that opened me up to,
uh,
um,
the,
the world of light and the world of a higher possibility beyond suicide and,
you know,
nihilism and all that.
It was out how you were approaching life.
Yeah.
You know,
what do you think the cause of that is,
is that the environmental is a behaviorals and pattern that you get into pro?
Well,
let's see.
I was 20,
21 and getting,
uh,
and probably there's something chemical going on.
Hormonal changes.
I was wondering whether I was crazy.
Um,
and,
uh,
I had a steady diet of a kind of nihilistic existentialist authors and it
reinforced the sense of absurdity because I thought that was what sophisticated,
uh,
artists would,
put,
want to put into their work,
was a healthy dose of nihilism and cynicism and sarcasm and all that.
And,
and,
uh,
yet that also felt very wrong.
And,
uh,
so it's very competitive.
I don't know.
And I,
so I,
anyway,
I was struggling with has kind of polarity kind of situation and,
and prone to extremes and things like that.
So,
you know,
with,
with a,
uh,
kind of,
my prayer,
uh,
in the morning was basically,
you know,
God if you exist,
show yourself because I'm tired of life,
you know,
at 20 water.
Right.
Oh my God,
that's so crazy.
And so it was kind of like a challenge.
It was kind of like,
yeah,
right.
Show me.
And so,
uh,
and I was,
nothing happened.
It's art school.
I was saying goodbye to my professor on the corner,
around the corner comes Alison in a VW says,
Hey,
I'm having a party later tonight.
why don't you come on over?
And the professor picks me up and says,
Hey,
I've got some clue and acid.
Uh,
and uh,
so hey,
I was going to kill myself.
So acid.
Yeah,
what a cool professor.
You don't get those kind of professors anymore.
It was at Columbus College of art and design.
You know,
I was out and,
uh,
the museum school in Boston.
In Boston.
Yeah.
That's where we met.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
And a conceptual art.
Where's that cars?
Uh,
let's see.
It's on the Fenway,
you know,
uh,
near Gardner Museum where the,
where the Museum of fine artists.
I grew up in Newton.
Yeah.
And uh,
I went back recently.
It was a really interesting,
I was,
we were driving around,
I forgot,
like how historic certain parts of boss God.
Yeah.
When you look at graveyards,
graveyards that are from the 16 hundreds,
and you know,
really old buildings like,
wow,
I forgot hot.
Like this is,
this is a historic town.
Well,
I always felt very much at home in Boston.
Did you hang around with any Irish drunks?
Cause that would change your mind,
the quickness,
Irish drunks on coke.
So that's,
I knew a lot of those Italian woods as well.
Don't want to discriminate.
The people that I liked was the kind of philosophical tradition that was there.
I loved Emerson friends,
right.
And call her and uh,
and William James there at Harvard and then later Tim leary and,
and Ron doss guys.
And so there was a tradition of a kind of altered states and they,
they did a lot of the experimentation,
the original experiments with uh,
uh,
Walder Panky when he did the Good Friday experiment.
Waits.
Amazing city as far as education goes.
I think that has more colleges per capita than anywhere else in the world or in
the country rather.
And um,
I also think you think about it like Harvard and Mit,
both in the same city that,
what are those?
I mean it's Cambridge,
but what are the odds of that?
Cambridge is basically Boston.
It's the same thing.
It's like,
wow,
what a crazy town for smart people.
Oh my God,
you're so smart.
Why would they be there?
It's so cold.
Well,
it,
they hunker in yeah.
And work hard.
Yeah.
That makes it,
makes you a hard worker,
that's for damn sure.
Grow up with a work ethic.
You know,
I grew up,
I learned how to work hard because every around me worked hard.
Look at you.
They got lucky now you,
well for sure.
Trust me,
it was a lot of luck involved.
But you know,
throwing up with people in Boston.
It really,
definitely when that fucking winter comes,
man,
you gotta be prepared.
I'd love California,
but there's something about it.
Like I even look at my kids and I'm like,
you know when to do you good to freeze your ass off every now and then.
Good to realize that you got to get in the house because it's cold outside.
You know,
to know that that shit's out there.
I think there's a humility that comes with having to deal with weather and
unfortunately as we're saying this podcast,
a bunch of people died in Oklahoma with a horrible tornado.
So you know,
we had to twisters acknowledge I'll sound that is and how fucking crazy it is
that there's a part of the world where the sky becomes an angry machine monster,
you know,
spinning wind that picks up Semitrailers and sends him flying through the air.
That is how horrific cows.
What's that move out of Oklahoma?
Well,
a lot of them can't man.
A lot of this is the problem.
A lot of people are poor and they've been there for years and the family's
there.
It's not that easy to just kind of pack up your shit.
Go to Michigan.
It's
cheaper that Ms. Definitely more bullets though.
Yeah,
maybe around Detroit apparently.
Right.
Detroit is like the worst place in the world to be a book.
They say that Detroit is a 47% illiteracy rate in Detroit.
Did you make that up?
I just made it up.
That's hilarious.
It's crazy.
If you really stop and think about it at 47% illiteracy rate,
like what is going on?
Like who is w no one's paying attention to anybody like,
like the cover.
The government should absolutely focus on situations like that.
The idea that we shouldn't intervene in places where it's gotten so out of hand
that half the people can't read like that should be thought of as an epidemic
because all of those people that can't read or going to give birth to children
that probably can't read either.
And you have thousands if not millions of people who can't read and then they're
going to enter into the world unprepared,
unprepared to communicate,
to exchange information,
to be able to find things out for themselves.
I have to take a bunch of people's words for things he can't read things.
I mean there's so much involved in being illiterate.
The fact that there's like millions of potential crazy people that are going to
go through life completely illiterate in 2013 and no one's up in arms about
that.
It's really kind of shocking.
It is.
And at uh,
something,
you know,
each one of us has to focus on in whatever way we can.
Yeah.
It's hard to make a person,
it's hard to raise a human being.
It's not an easy thing.
And when we're looking at human beings that are being raised in like really
terrible conditions,
and it should be like one of the first things like the whole world concentrates
on before you concentrate on,
I mean it sounds so hippy,
but it seems like if you really want to have a happy life,
you've got to be doing more good than you are harm.
And there's,
there's gotta be a way to do that first.
Does gotta be a way to say,
look,
there's x amount of people in the world that are starving,
let's all globally chip in to try to stop that from happening so that these
starving people don't have starving children who never get a chance to get some
momentum in life and be comfortable and happy.
It never comes.
It never comes to just give them a chance.
Like,
wouldn't it be like the most important thing you could ever do it like as a,
as a race to stop the worst conditions to stop the worst conditions with Sam?
Kinison had the best bit about that.
Oh,
it was so cruel,
but it was so amazing what he's saying.
He's talking about Ethiopian children have,
they have those commercials.
He's always like,
you should just fix yourself some dinner.
He's sitting there and it's commercial and it's like blue cheese help him.
Why don't you send it?
He's like,
cause like,
why don't you help him?
You're only five feet away.
He's the guy behind the camera.
We've got a Snicker's bar going.
Not now.
It's not the case.
It was at one of the best bits ever.
And it's like we have deserts in America too.
We just don't live in a mass hall.
Like he said that we,
you know,
I forget how it call.
Is it something about we uh,
yeah,
we,
we sent,
we came over here with your food
and occurred to us that we would need food if you,
people would move where the food is like you live in a fucking desert and he
grabs him when he puts his face in the sands.
His then is that sand?
No,
it's going to be a thousand years from now.
Fucking sand.
It's terrible.
Mean Pill.
So me,
see,
you're all in.
Even though Kansans dead long dead still.
It's,
Ooh,
it's such a mean bit,
but it was hilarious.
It was,
they'd crossed that line of being fucking mean,
but so funny.
Like,
Oh,
you motherfucker.
Oh God,
he was,
he was a wild motherfucker.
Sam Kennison.
Okay.
Credit.
And we were talking about Hicks before the show started.
You know,
that I,
we,
we both thought that like Hicks was like the first truly like psychedelic
comedian who had a psychedelic ideas that he was putting forth.
It's,
you know,
some of them weren't even that funny.
They were just incredibly profound,
uh,
that it was in the middle of some other shit that was fun.
It was what was so weird about it.
Right,
right.
And,
uh,
that's how he would drop those meaningful,
you know,
mine bombs into your psyche so that they kind of melted and,
uh,
stayed,
you know,
he,
he knew how to kind of stay in your consciousness with,
uh,
a new,
perception
and a lot of his stuff's still holds up.
You know,
all,
I haven't,
especially if you haven't heard it before,
which I still holds up because what he was saying about the Bush administration,
the first Bush administration,
by the way,
that's,
you know,
that was when he was railing against the machine.
It's just like you could just take it and substitute the words and it works.
Today.
It worked with George W it works with Obama.
I mean,
it just,
the material works.
Just substitute this guy for that guy.
And he was,
it's still relevant.
And so he gave birth to like a whole completely different style comedian like
that.
The style of comedian that came after him was like,
they wanted to like educate you,
which is really weird because some of them were idiots.
So,
uh,
there was a on the wall of,
the back,
the green room at the Dallas,
uh,
know the Atlanta punchline.
There's a big sign that says,
don't stop trying to be Hicks.
Oh,
quit trying to be Hicks.
Yeah.
Because there was so many guys that were doing that.
There are so many guys.
Cheng.
Wow.
Yeah.
It was just so,
it was so amazing to watch that.
He like,
I mean,
Doctor Admit Goswami,
he's a physicist on those.
A particle guys had a funny thing to say about,
uh,
about people that were sort of faking it and he was like,
it goes,
let them who goes,
I let them use the word quantum if they don't understand it because maybe it'll
have the seek to understand it now.
And I remember hearing,
I'm like,
wow,
that's so profound.
That's interesting.
I would've never thought that far ahead.
Like he's like letting people fake it,
not calling them on it just so they just
keep looking into it.
Okay.
If they're intrigued,
then why should he be the stop?
Exactly.
Why should it be like you listen bitch,
you know,
you don't know what you're talking about.
Uh Huh.
Uh,
made a lot of people were of psychedelics too.
There was a lot of people that did not know anything about like heroic doses or
any of that shit.
Like Hicks was like the first stand up comedian to ever talk about things that
way.
The other ones that would talk about mushrooms,
it would be like,
well,
hey,
we did most rooms and you know,
we got old goofy and Bobby thought he was a horse.
You know,
that's usually the story.
It was never like,
it wasn't like what Hicks was describing.
It was like,
what is this guy saying?
Because how come it's different than everybody else that takes mushrooms?
And I think just,
it was so interesting and fascinating when he would talk about it,
that it just led a lot of people to explore that.
I think he was,
uh,
another,
kind of apostle and a a and a kind of a nightclub setting.
Yeah.
I mean,
in digitally still is,
you know,
we can still hear it
words exactly.
Because we resonate with the authenticity that and the rawness that he
projected.
And with a Psychedelic,
uh,
perspective that allowed him a kind of brutal honesty.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
and yet,
there was something remarkably magnetic because he,
he was like a laser about the truth.
It seemed.
That was what he wanted,
uh,
to be about even at the,
you know,
uh,
and to,
to reveal a,
um,
I kind of underlying darkness was something that he was an expert.
Yeah.
He really was.
And um,
he,
you know,
he had a lot of references that he would do,
use it as material that would make you seek out of the shit,
like with Terence Mckenna would call heroic dose,
you know,
and I was like,
who the fuck is Terence Mckenna?
And then I started reading about trends,
but can I go,
Whoa,
this guy,
holy shit,
I serve food of the gods.
And I was like,
oh my God.
Like,
where's this Guy Ben?
You know,
I mean Hicks exposes people or did expose.
Yes,
he did.
And then once he got into the mechanic door,
then you were off to the races.
Yeah.
Once you start listening to those Mckenna mp3s that are available online,
you want to talk about something that will just crack your consciousness.
Those,
uh,
Mckenna mp3s of that,
some of those lectures that he gave,
he just what he thought.
God,
I had an a very strange way of thinking.
Yes.
I used to think of him as the,
uh,
the spokesman k for the mushroom,
you know,
that,
uh,
he was kind of plugged in to that,
but he and his brother both,
uh,
extraordinary in their,
um,
uh,
intersection with the plant kingdom and the fungal kingdom and cat Mckenna as
well,
who
continues to work at botanical dimensions.
The,
uh,
what is,
it was a story they told of a lot shoe Hara or they,
uh,
they took too much and Dennis kind of went,
he went radio silent for a couple of weeks while completely crazy for awhile.
Yes.
That they're,
you know,
you're dealing with like dinner plate size mushrooms and they're eating them all
day would,
whoa.
What'd you like?
10 interviewed Dennis?
I'm on.
Oh,
you've had them all right?
Yeah,
he did.
Oh,
he was great with the brothers of the screaming of best.
Yeah,
yeah,
we talked about is awesome.
We just talked about psychedelics and we talked very specifically about the,
the actual science behind the possibility of psychedelics creating language and
especially as particularly psilocybin,
and he was explaining how,
you know,
it would make sense that language was created through the use of,
of silicide been by virtue of the effect of silicide when hasn't a very
scientific way that I can't recreate and traps.
Yeah,
and I was like,
oh,
I never even heard anybody say it that way before,
but that completely makes sense.
Obviously one theory and I don't understand really what he's saying.
It just sounds awesome.
You know?
I don't know whether or not there's some science to it.
Other people might disagree with it.
Let's say that it's a common place for people to want to express themselves
creatively in the wake of a psychedelic experience.
Yeah.
I was going to ask you though,
why do you think that is that people would dismiss that?
Why do you think it is that people would ridicule that?
Like someone saying that you actually learned something from a psychedelic
experience.
You say that to the average person and then they'll look at you with ridicule,
like,
wow.
How did that happen,
do you think?
Well,
I,
uh,
I have like the,
listeners,
uh,
to help us think of a word to a Paice that in the same context as homophobia or,
misogyny or,
uh,
you know,
something like a racism,
like,
uh,
why do people who alter their consciousness or who speak of it inspire,
the,
uh,
hysteria in people that don't take them,
you know?
And he said,
actually,
that's a great,
great line.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
I think that for a lot of folks,
they,
first of all the equate drugs with bad,
you know,
they think of you drugs.
The problem is meth is a drug too.
And meth wrecks lives to put cocaine fucks people up.
But then there's pot,
which doesn't,
and then there's mushrooms,
which does,
these are,
you know,
they're all drugs though.
It's like,
wow.
It is,
I mean,
you could look at some as a food as it,
and it's better maybe to classify some as a sacrament that have been that
sacrament,
uh,
for longer than they were a quote drug.
Um,
they were a way to that people connected with the,
uh,
with the higher dimensions.
What does the term entheogens,
what is the actual,
uh,
translation
n Theo,
Theo of courses,
God or the divine.
And Anthea would be the divine within
bunch of dudes that are really do she just decided the name their son Theo after
hearing that
my boy,
the God,
God Deo faulting.
Awesome.
So that's what entheogenic means.
Yeah.
So it's from the God.
It's,
um,
a,
a way to discover or a,
um,
a substance that allows you to discover the God within or the divine within it,
within.
I don't blame people that are,
uh,
that discriminated against.
So I did dogs if they haven't had psychedelics.
I think it's just an ignorance thing.
I think the people have a lot of,
uh,
bad ideas and then don't necessarily think it's their responsibility to be right
about something that they haven't experienced themselves.
And that is,
you know,
in society,
it sort of is,
it's looked down upon,
it's looked down upon to alter your consciousness like that,
that if you do it,
you're probably looking to escape reality.
That's like the standard take on it.
Yet many of these people would consider themselves to be religious people.
Sure.
A lot of them,
if you look at the foundations of all world religions as we've just gone through
it,
yeah.
Uh,
we can see that they were based on this visionary mystical experience,
which is what we're saying is a value for everyone.
Yeah.
But Alex,
that was thousands of years ago.
They don't want it anymore.
All right.
If Jesus came around today,
no one would believe him.
There was some dude that was claiming that he was the son of God.
You would give wisdom to everybody.
They'd probably put them in Guantanamo Bay.
There's no way they would let that guy just run around running shit.
A lot of,
uh,
people,
God,
uh,
inspired people are on the loose,
you know,
they're just like spores.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But there's,
but the idea of the one,
a messiah coming back,
a Magical Messiah with power to branch out from the dead.
Did I,
did I already say my theory about the second coming?
No.
Okay.
I love to hear it.
You're smiling like a little kid right now.
Okay.
Cause I thought I repeat myself endlessly,
but,
uh,
welcome to the podcast we do here.
Okay.
So the,
the first coming of Christ,
uh,
was the revelation of the,
connection of,
uh,
of basically of the divinity of humanity.
Right?
That was the revelation.
And,
uh,
the,
second coming,
uh,
through,
kind of idiosyncratic,
uh,
tradition,
that is,
uh,
coming out of the,
South America.
A lot of IOWASCA churches all over the world are,
um,
drinking,
uh,
and contacting this higher dimension,
through the IOWASCA.
And,
uh,
I called,
I in no demeaning way,
I call it the green Jesus,
uh,
because,
and Grain Mary really,
uh,
because it's,
revealing the divinity of nature and there's nothing more important right now.
Uh,
then recognizing the divinity and the sacredness of nature and saving the life
web in whatever ways we can,
uh,
somehow turning our ship around from a self destructive species.
You know,
this is the tight place where heading into
it is,
but it isn't always been linked.
US,
isn't this the Yin and the Yang that makes people human?
Perhaps the pushing the pole.
Sometimes we need to rally against an impending doom pod.
I know it's,
it's a part of being a person.
We're goofy.
We don't want to cram for tests where we're adolescent species and wildly
destructive.
Yeah.
Uh,
we only exist through the grace of the,
um,
the,
the kinds of spirits that are tolerant because we're so creative.
I think that,
and they hope that we will,
uh,
work on this together with the intelligence that's,
that's seeding today.
And we've also been born in a super lucky spot as far as the history of
humanity.
We didn't have to go through the people trying to make it across the,
the West with wagon trains and we didn't have to go through any of that.
We were lucky we have internet.
Perhaps we'll be loading in some astral dimension and they,
uh,
in the next lifetime that's possible to do you,
do you have,
do you feel you have a responsibility from,
you know,
your,
the fact that you have this,
uh,
this,
this voice and you are looked at as this sort of psychedelic visionary guy.
Do you feel like you have a responsibility to try to get information out?
Things that you've learned,
things that you think possibly could help people?
Cause you obviously have a vision of things and you obviously have a very well
thought out view of humanity and of consciousness.
Do you,
do you feel that you have an obligation to express these thoughts?
I think that anyone who experiences the deeper realms maybe as it turned about
and their conscience,
it's not just about higher consciousness,
but there's a,
a sense that if you're connected everyone and with everything,
then what's your moral responsibility or your ethical,
uh,
response to your interconnectedness.
And so,
uh,
if there's a bunch of hippies just took their pants off right now,
it's like I can't take it to the love.
It's too much love,
man.
Well,
I think that,
uh,
there's a natural resistance to allowing it to be as magnificent as it actually
is.
Also a fear of the unknown too.
Totally.
And people that haven't had it,
I think that that's why I don't fault them.
The ones who are anti,
you know,
a lot of people associate drugs with you're ruining your life,
not with saving your life.
They're capable of both.
Totally.
In my case,
it was the other was the saving my life and meeting my wife and 39 years later,
here we are.
You know,
whatever seed was born in the saving of a life,
uh,
and uh,
you know,
giving a literal turning point and saying,
can you see me now?
You know,
well,
switch literally was turned on and you became a different person.
Like shedding a,
uh,
a cocoon and the,
you know,
Caterpillar becomes a butterfly or whatever the fuck happens whenever you have a
really profound experience.
But some people don't do that.
Some people do.
They,
this is what I say is that a really profound psychedelic experience like
control,
alt,
delete for your consciousness where your brain can reboots the fresh operating
system and there's only one folder on the desktop and the desktop folder says my
old bullshit.
And you can either open it up and go right back into these predetermined
patterns of behavior once a psychedelic experience has faded because it be more
comfortable that way.
Then sort of reassessing the way you've been living your life or you know,
you can hit delete and try to keep going and do DMT again.
Trying to get right back there right when it stops being fresh.
Just reintroduced that my,
Oh,
there it is.
Okay.
I got it.
Thanks.
They're sandbags.
Evolutionary toe hold that,
uh,
you can,
shine our light toward your future that you're headed toward a rather than
depend on the,
uh,
effects of past behavior.
Wow.
Yeah.
You know what's been really tripping me out,
it was how many people that I know that are starting to have a semi at least
psychedelic experiences from doing yoga.
You know,
I've had maybe one time in my life or I did yoga and I felt like I was high.
I felt like I was high on marijuana and that's what it felt like at the end of
it.
It was like,
wow.
It's just like whatever it is that you've stepped,
that switch that you can hit when you do the right poses for the right amount of
time with the right amount of energy.
There's a weird switch that you hit at the end where I was literally high.
But that's as far as I've ever taken it.
I've never had a hallucination.
I've never actually projected,
I've never,
but I have heard some of the fucking craziest things from people that practice
Kundalini Yoga that if I didn't know them really well and the way they were
telling it to me,
it's like so matter of factly.
I would say this guy's crazy.
He's just making up a bunch of shit except for the one time that I got myself
high cause I was really high.
I mean I was high.
I felt great.
I had love in my heart.
I wanted to hug people.
I,
I felt like colors were brighter,
sounds were cleaner.
I really felt really high.
And,
uh,
it was just from doing yoga and I was like,
if that's possible,
I,
I've,
I've never really continually practice Kundalini,
but the people who really get into,
yeah,
Pranayama is and all that,
they say that there's a wave length that you can hit where you tap into that,
whatever it is,
the pineal gland,
the DMT factory and just shot,
boom,
open up the doorway and punch right through.
And that you can do it through yoga.
Yes,
absolutely.
You've done three yoga.
Uh,
yes.
And there are different,
uh,
kind to like the,
you could have the idea for [inaudible] to be honest with you,
for Antionne really came,
came about.
First of all,
through,
uh,
Alison and I had a routine of a yoga and then meditation.
And,
uh,
during that period,
basically,
uh,
instead of like kind of forcing myself to imagine something,
I was saying,
well,
God,
what do you want?
You know,
what would you like me to put on?
Uh,
there?
And so it showed this,
the inner connected kind of God had type thing.
It's perfect.
So God's on it.
Okay.
Mail.
Just do something like that.
Yeah,
come on.
Here it is.
Okay,
thank you.
So,
you know,
uh,
that's on the notch,
I guess.
You know,
I mean,
yeah.
Or not on the Nache ever,
dude,
let's be honest.
Exactly.
You're so psychedelic anyway from point a,
you're,
you naturally psychedelic.
And then on top of that,
all the things you've done,
how could you ever pretend that you ever on the notch,
if you're experienced too much to be on the match?
Well,
your reference point is now more cosmic then,
uh,
sort of,
isolated.
Yes.
And you feel more connected with people because,
and it must happen to you.
Um,
you have a community,
you have,
uh,
met with many of the people that come out to see you over your tour and things
like that.
Um,
how has your sense of community,
uh,
evolved in your understanding?
That's a good question.
Well,
what I've found is that,
um,
by doing something like a podcast,
having conversations with people like you,
and you know,
my friends that come on you,
you're,
you're sitting,
you're putting out like the kind of,
uh,
conversations that we're having right now.
You putting these out to people that live in places where they don't know
anybody like you.
They can't get a guy like you to sit down for three hours.
I couldn't get you to sit down for three hours and just talk like this unless
we're going to do a podcast.
I mean,
it probably could,
but this is the way to do it,
you know,
so everybody can be in on it as well.
But that's one of the best things for me about this podcast is that I'm getting
to talk to like these people like Chris Ryan or Danieli Bolelli are all these
interesting people that I get to talk to on a regular basis.
To me,
that's a,
a beautiful little situation that I've stumbled into.
And uh,
for me,
I'm very,
I feel very fortunate just to be able to have all these conversations with
people.
And then now there's a sense of obligation because I know that people enjoy
these conversations and I want to,
and I,
I don't want to ever have them think that I'm not going to do it anymore.
We're going to keep just going like,
it's fun.
I know you enjoy it.
I enjoy it too.
It's totally mutual.
Thanks a lot.
I'm glad you like it.
And I think with that,
it's with that attitude we've,
we've created,
uh,
this,
this group of people that listen to the podcast and maybe they've never had like
really introspective conversations with people.
You know,
maybe they've never really thought about living in another part of the world or
maybe they've never thought about expanding the life that they live outside of
this one realm of consciousness that they've inhabited their whole life.
One way of looking at the world,
whether it's racist or,
or glutinous or whether they've just been abusing their body or whether they
just been lazy about getting things done.
And when you,
you hear a podcast where you get a chance to see all these different people's
takes on things.
You know,
from Everlast a singer too,
my friend Joey Diaz and all these different people's takes on things,
they're all different and dynamic and all having access to that.
It's like having a bunch of like really smart friends around you all the time.
So if you can listen to these podcasts,
not everybody's really smart,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not saying we're,
we're all really smart.
I'm saying some of them are really smart.
But if you get a chance to have these interesting conversations and they enrich
people's consciousness because you might be stuck in a bad spot.
I've been in a bad spot in my life where I didn't have a lot of cool people to
talk to.
You couldn't just tune into a podcast,
you know?
And so my sense of community is sort of a,
it's one become a thing of obligation of on an a happy obligation.
But I definitely think we're obligated to continue to provide content.
And it's,
uh,
you know,
I remember being addicted to radio shows or different bands when I was a kid and
you want more stuff,
you want constantly more stuff.
So we're,
we're,
you know,
that's a big part of community with me,
but it's also
one of the most,
the happiest things that I've gotten from this podcast is people coming up to me
telling me that it changed the way they,
they think about things telling me that now they're,
they're happy telling me that now they eat healthy,
telling me that now they just stop being an asshole to people that they realize
they were really just frustrated and they need to get their shit together and
then it's over and over and over again.
You know,
and that,
that sense of community,
I mean it was completely accidental.
We didn't set out to try to create some sort of a,
a group that sort of tunes into,
we just hope people enjoy the podcast.
We didn't think it was going to be a,
I know it,
it's a very interesting thing when do a group of supportive listeners become a
community?
And it's kind of like,
uh,
we see,
that today people would like to gather in a lot of different places and,
uh,
to,
coalesce for,
uh,
a few hours and,
have a temporary community.
Well,
I think we'd like to have a full community,
but we don't trust people that knocked at fucking cookie.
Not everybody has their shit together.
No,
you can't just walk into my house.
You might be nuts.
And that's true.
By the way.
I'm tired.
I just got home from work.
I'd really like to just watch TV.
I don't want you to come over my house.
So there's a certain boundary that we all have to set up.
That's why the church model of the,
uh,
you know,
there's a time when you devote some time to,
uh,
this other thing too,
that's going on,
that's more of a community thing and that's why I ask about it because it's
something that we've been thinking about a lot.
It's going to happen on its own.
It's a,
people are going to gravitate.
I told you,
although the,
all the fringe people all over the planet are coming to you.
My friend [inaudible] going to zoom in on it along with some cops.
Probably.
You're going to get some undercover cops that are going to try to pretend to be
your friends and try to get deep into the organization and find out you're for
real.
And then eventually they'll admit it to you.
It'll give him some acid.
I'll tell you they're a cop.
No apologize.
And you'll say it's okay and you'll give up.
I don't,
we don't cry.
Give anything to anyone really.
Uh,
I'm saying advocate that much.
We do tell the truth about what happened to us.
And I'm a,
and I'm of the belief that,
uh,
the discovery of,
of LSD 70 years ago this year,
um,
is,
uh,
quite a miraculous occurrence and probably have,
a religious importance to humanity in the great scheme of things.
And I think 70 years after the crucifixion,
basically,
it wasn't going so well for the Christians,
you know?
And,
uh,
so there's,
time,
you know that.
And that's why I was trying to think of,
oh,
this is kind of like a civil rights issue,
that it is,
uh,
pointing toward a higher freedom of consciousness and a,
the end special,
um,
uh,
places.
I'm not saying they,
these are not a potentially dangerous substances,
you know,
and in the wrong hands of the wrong time and things like that,
it's can be a tangible,
a weapon even,
you know.
So,
uh,
there,
there definitely,
uh,
things that shouldn't be toyed with and some people should stay very clear of
them.
Uh,
they happen to be,
uh,
something that gave us tremendous insight and I think many other people as well,
not because I said so,
but because people naturally have discovered this.
It's part of,
it's a part of contemporary culture even.
It's just a weird thing that we have.
Once we write things down on paper and we say this is a law,
even when it gets to the overwhelming breaking point,
and it's probably,
it's probably not there with psychedelics,
I think it is with pot.
But when it gets to the undeniable breaking point where people just,
they,
they're like,
no,
like 70% can say they favor legalization.
Like oop,
sorry.
It's just,
it's not up for grabs.
The federal government's not really interested in what your real oh,
70%.
That's great.
Call us when it's 1000000% and will still tell you to fuck yourself.
It's like they just,
it's,
the laws don't make any sense.
And it only points at this point at this,
this is time to suppression.
This is the only,
that's the only thing that makes sense.
They're nonlethal okay.
They're not lethal life changing.
And there's a lot of people that give it five stars on Yelp.
Okay.
You know,
this means people events a bad times on mushrooms.
That's a fact.
But if,
uh,
if mushrooms had a Yelp page,
it would be a motherfucker.
That shit would be filled with stars and there would be like,
but link to,
it'd be every one of those reviews would say more at the bottom.
You'd have to click to get an extra pair of mantra to infinite stars.
Are there?
Yeah,
they wouldn't.
It would be.
Yeah.
If you had less than five stars from mushrooms,
you're an asshole.
Give it five stars.
Stupid.
It was the best thing that ever happened to you.
I mean they're,
they're the Johns Hopkins University.
He's now starting to public studies saying that just one mushroom trip 20 years
ago.
It was a profound effect on personality and improve people's outlook and,
and their level of happiness.
Like it makes it can make people happier.
That sounds so stupid that it's illegal.
Literally.
How many people are like you?
How many people are like,
well,
I just needed that reset and with a loving person that I meet,
I have a great time and then all of a sudden,
boom,
I'm off to the races on a totally different track.
How many people have to say that before we,
we as a culture go,
well isn't this,
this Alex Gray is like way cooler.
He's like a bit way better look.
He makes amazing art.
He's a nice guy.
He's happy,
he seems fulfilled.
He's trying to create a center of beautiful building where people can come and
worship all this stuff.
Like,
what,
what is wrong with that?
What's going on here?
Like what are we trying to protect people from time protect.
It sounds like you're trying to protect people from enlightenment.
That would sound preposterous.
What kind of,
what kind of a benevolent leader would you be if you try to protect people from
potential enlightenment?
Or are you scared of potential enlightenment yourself and knowing that if you do
take mushrooms,
you can't put on the bulletproof vest and tear gas to kids.
You can't,
you're not going to do it.
You're not,
you're not going to be the pepper spray cop when the kids are protesting because
they're not going to be able to conscience
[inaudible] and you,
you learn to do
yeah.
Do that gig anymore.
Yeah.
You got to get a new gig.
Or if you do do it,
you'll have nightmares.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Imagine doing mushrooms and then pepper spraying kids.
Oh my God.
The demonic nightmares that you would have for decades.
It's,
uh,
and,
and then the habits that you'd a form to avoid a confronting them.
Yeah.
Ooh,
Jesus.
He would become a fucking gambling addicts for sure.
Three cigarettes in your mouth at the same time
looking at bet on a roach cross at a parking lot,
you're better than anything.
There's whatever to distract yourself from.
It's a lot of people out there that just got started off in a bad way mean it's
true.
And very few things can help them except psychedelic experiences.
Are there one of the best ways to affect those?
And like we said,
it doesn't have to be a drug.
You can get psychedelic experience just through meditation,
through.
If you,
you've,
you've practiced it enough,
allegedly,
he says he's done it,
you know,
I've never got there other than getting high,
you're saying like doing the yoga and meditation,
even not for a long time.
There are many different approaches to meditation.
You know,
from the simplest kind of watching your breath,
uh,
to,
kind of,
uh,
Alison talks about an aesthetic kind of reception of considering each moment
like,
uh,
you know,
for the beautiful special,
unique thing that it is.
And,
uh,
but like we listened to music,
you know,
we listened to with,
uh,
an ear of appreciation and things like that.
If we,
if we had an aesthetic scrutiny and could see the beauty of,
of,
uh,
of our cosmic situation,
you know,
that we evolved to this point where we can talk to each other through a network
of,
uh,
intelligence and light,
and share,
uh,
potential,
connection,
uh,
community even have,
a new wave of consciousness that's,
uh,
you know,
spread throughout the world.
You know,
I feel like these are these podcasts and things like that are the,
are the mushroom fruit of,
uh,
my Celio body of underground intelligences that interweave.
And uh,
then they pop out on these special occasions.
And,
uh,
well it's a door to open people up to people like you to new possibilities,
new ways,
new ways of thinking.
And sometimes that's all you need is just one unique idea that's putting your
head by someone that you don't even know.
Just listening to him talk to somebody else and that thought sends you off in a
different direction.
A person's words can be psychedelic,
is I'll a lot of different things.
Childbirth can be psychedelic.
There's a lot of different things that happened to you in this life that are
our,
you know,
we,
we think of psychedelics as being hallucinations and we think of them as being
sort of a child's fair.
But you know,
the reality is that there's a lot that comes out of them that it's very
difficult to get any other way and the way it comes out so reliably,
it's like no one is like mushrooms work for almost everyone on the planet.
Like no one's immune.
Like you could be out of focus and not really get there with,
and Delaney,
you really just can never really get your shit and groove and you just have a
bad class.
You take five grams of mushrooms,
you're off to the moon,
no matter if you like it or not,
you're going to,
you're going to get sucked into the wake and hopefully you can let go ride it
out and be okay.
But you might just clench up and it might just go haywire.
Yes,
yes.
And that's the,
uh,
that's why you're always choosing a supportive and safe,
setting,
uh,
if possible and in under ideal conditions,
even those that you don't have to worry about anything about it,
that you can relax totally in that you're supported by loving friends,
uh,
so that you feel that you can go as deep and as,
you know,
as high as possible.
And,
uh,
with those conditions and your favorite music,
we like to use a kind of a spiritual,
we up with Ding like Bach and stuff like that.
Kind of heavy for some people,
but I thought I was going to say Christian rock now,
but I'm like,
uh,
you know,
like,
uh,
we used to listen to a musical offering all the time and it's so airy,
but it favored the tripping mind with all the few gigs and things like that.
The infinitizes,
uh,
Israeli,
their inbox,
I forgot to
tweet people and tell them that we're live.
Ah,
this flux start over.
No,
we don't have to start all with live for a while.
Hold on
for a while with,
oh,
me too.
Sorry.
Sorry,
folks listening.
That's good.
So do you ever go back to Columbus,
Ohio?
I actually will.
All my friends went to CCAD and that's where actually the coffee in college I
was actually supposed to go to,
but I ended up not.
Um,
do you ever go back?
Do you ever visit,
I mean,
I bet you're like a superhero there now,
so,
or ah,
well I think they a great return home has not really happened so much.
Um,
but I do visit my mother and a family when things say baby.
Yeah.
Well we'll see.
You know,
where a,
there's some festival things that are happening in the region and,
uh,
this year we're going perhaps,
to another part of the world.
Uh,
but then at some point I think we'll coordinate it.
What part of the Hudson Valley are you,
is it the Hudson valley that you're putting this?
Uh,
yes.
Where is it that we're in the town of wappinger and a wop inter is a beautiful
town that's right on the Hudson River and,
uh,
it's related to Wappingers falls.
And [inaudible] is the name of the native people,
uh,
who inhabited the region 400 years ago.
And,
uh,
they were,
wonderful,
uh,
kind of series of tribes that went all the way down.
[inaudible] a w a p.
and I'm not,
that's a cool name is,
it's amazing.
It's,
it's got resonances with many creatures and,
uh,
with a kind of a good attitude.
They had a,
uh,
a,
awesome,
uh,
idea about the Hudson River.
Uh,
we call it the Hudson now,
but I used to be,
uh,
the,
[inaudible] Connie took,
uh,
the great flow that goes both ways and,
that makes sense.
It's a tidal river and,
uh,
it goes up right to our town,
right?
Two around there,
and then it goes back to the ocean.
It's,
it's just amazing kind of town.
Is it?
So,
uh,
well it's,
it's been many things and,
uh,
it's,
right now I'd say it's an evolving town and,
uh,
the place that we inhabit,
it used to be called deer hill and deer hill was a United Church of Christ,
uh,
congregation and also an interfaith,
kind of camp.
So they had a very,
um,
trans denominational or interfaith kind of approach to spirituality and they had
it on the market for like seven years.
And finally when we found each other,
we felt like we had a lot in common that we,
our message was,
uh,
I an attempted at a universal message of spirituality and interconnectedness and
using nature as a setting for this kind of sole renewing,
uh,
kind of surrounding in a creative environment.
So we do,
uh,
all kinds of,
creativity classes there from dancing and,
uh,
and uh,
movement and,
uh,
the yoga and meditation and things like that too.
How much of the places where the outside is,
the inside is done,
it's just the outside needs to be completed with the artwork with end fee on,
uh,
the,
what we have is a,
uh,
old carriage house and it's been structurally reinforced and a w we've actually
put quite a bit into it already in a ceiling and shoring it up.
But then we have to take the roof off and we have to establish a new steel
foundations in all the corners.
And,
uh,
we're building the heads 16 feet away from the entry to the brick building.
So what you'll have is it large atrium in front of the brick building when you
walk into La,
into NT on and with this,
uh,
there'll be the reception,
there'll be,
you know,
bathroom and coke because it and things like that,
but there'll also be a fountain had there,
uh,
that will mount against the wall of this old carriage house.
So you'll see this dramatic kind of 75 by 23 foot high,
a wall of brick.
Uh,
and this is,
this it right here.
We're looking at it right now.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's up here as well.
Uh,
yeah.
Put it,
pulled it all the way back,
Brian for a second.
The,
the uh,
the construction looks like pretty in depth.
Like you guys did a lot of,
a lot of stuff for the Plos.
Oh yeah.
It's been,
are you living inside of that as well?
No,
we are not.
There's the brick carriage house and uh,
so we're going to,
we've been showing it up.
Uh,
we found a nearby,
um,
construction companies that are specialists in ornamental casting of concrete.
And uh,
so this is led to this kind of a key to how we're going to actually build the
building.
So that's all going to be concrete.
Those faces.
Yes,
but it's a skin I thin skin of concrete about an inch thick and uh,
reinforced with steel and a class fiber reinforced kind of concrete.
And it's a very special,
uh,
kind of,
permanent.
Uh,
and then it's going to be sectioned and,
uh,
like these heads,
there's very repetitive kinds of elements to it.
So there'll be made on some sort of a gigantic mold or something like that.
And there'll be several of them reversed.
It will be a first,
it was,
I guess,
seeing in the imagination.
Uh,
thank you.
Transcendent visionary source.
And then I drew it and,
uh,
then I showed it to Ryan toddle,
who's an amazing,
uh,
digital sculptor and a visionary artist and he works at Disney actually during
the day.
And,
uh,
so he took this,
into three dimensions and,
uh,
made the actual three d model that's sized perfectly to the building.
So this will be printed out in sections and,
uh,
we'll have a,
basically a foam print out then,
uh,
we'll be corrected and things like that.
And then a mold will be taken from that.
Then,
uh,
for,
in that mold,
we shoot a,
this concrete,
uh,
thin,
kind of inch thick stuff.
It's got pins on the back that attached to a steel armature and that armature
attaches to the building.
Wow.
It's,
it's very exciting because it's a,
it's a real,
an actual thing.
It's incredibly ambitious and well,
you know,
look,
people always did sacred buildings,
you know,
and,
uh,
it's up.
She don't have to justify it to me.
I think it's awesome.
I'm just,
I mean,
you're like,
Hey,
they've always done this
tiny,
tiny little expression [inaudible] magnificent temples that are all over the
world and things,
you know,
I mean,
there are grand and we'll,
there's no pope behind you.
Horse carriage is filled with gold demand for construction.
There's people who are pledging 10 bucks and 30 bucks and I should tell them
they get something from that.
You have a bunch of different tiers set up,
different things that you get,
whether it's artwork or there's,
there's,
I think there's how many different levels do you have of a
possibilities?
They can,
we have so many,
we've got like a even original artwork,
um,
that,
uh,
has never been offered before and stuff.
So,
uh,
there's a,
a pdf with all kinds of art works and things like that and uh,
sketches and,
uh,
these,
these are worth the two admission for two to Ntl.
That's your coin,
your own money.
What are you doing?
You going too far?
I needed to take it down a notch.
Whatever you do.
Nobody has guns.
Okay.
That's,
they come down that now.
No guns ever.
Right.
You should really make that super strict.
Yeah.
Cause you're going to have a bunch of loons.
I go,
you know what,
I love,
I love you.
I love psychedelics,
but also of the second amendment.
We're going to rock when it comes and takes our compound.
Well we covered,
we try to have,
uh,
you know,
intelligent security that,
that,
uh,
that just so that things don't always stay cool.
You know what it would be though,
it'd be the cop that pretended to be one of you guys that would freak out and
pull his gun.
The real cops will come in and lock you guys down because you're a violent yet
guns.
That'd be what I would do if I was a cop.
So I was trying to shut you hippies down.
Well,
we actually have made friends with the local police because,
uh,
we're grateful.
Oh,
that's how,
for their service,
and that's a beautiful thing to say too.
I agree with that as well.
I get shit about that online because you always to tell people that I like cops.
But I think it's important to have police.
We absolutely depend on them.
AIESEC community.
And there's a lot of good ones you that people don't want to address that.
There's a lot of cops out there.
They're nice despite all the shit they see every day.
I've,
we have a friends who were sort of high up in that and the local region and,
and they're just some of the nicest people and most compassionate actually
because there they go to people who are in trouble mostly.
And then,
you know,
there absolutely are bad cops.
That's no doubt about it either.
Sure.
No one's making up for that.
But just saying there's,
there's a need for it and a lot of them are good.
And if you're in a community that's accepting you guys and,
and did you have a little weird thing where they didn't want you guys to be non
taxed?
Well,
we're still working that out.
You know,
they won't accept you as a regular religion.
It's a,
the church status is,
uh,
it,
see,
we're building sacred space,
right?
We hold a full moon ceremonies every month.
We hold our church.
Uh,
that sounds awesome.
And which was your neighbor?
And we have neighbors who loved to come over and they love to participate.
And we have people from all over the world who come.
And also this is before and theone really is there,
you know,
so there's a lot of four years we've been a waiting and,
and so now we've got a loan from a bank that is,
uh,
helping us out and we have the kickstarters coming,
you know,
it's,
we still have like nine days or something like that.
What,
we'll try to pump it up for you.
What kind of town is this?
This is like a town that accepts hippies.
They conserve that.
I'd say there's,
I'd say there's a healthy mix.
And what I find so,
uh,
really astonishing is the religious diversity.
Uh,
there's,
uh,
seek,
temple,
I believe there's Hindu temples,
there's a Tibetan Buddhist Stupa,
there's all in the town.
How many people were in his tone?
Just,
you know,
it's not,
it's not a large amount of taste.
One of those vortexes,
they're just a little wrong.
I think that the comedy store,
I think it's a little bit of a vortex.
Just beauty and,
uh,
you know,
according to our native American scholar,
uh,
Evan Pritchard,
he said that the,
uh,
our land may have been held sacred by the [inaudible] people as well.
So it's always been kind of in this,
uh,
you know,
sacred tradition and it was a church before you and yeah,
that's fascinating.
I always wondered why,
where are they,
how,
how you
pick a site for something like this.
You know,
I think it's really cool that you're doing it.
I think it's really fun.
It's exciting.
I know you have good intentions.
So,
yeah,
we're hopeful.
And uh,
these,
uh,
we met some of the neighbors and we tried to be considerate now about sound and
things like that.
And uh,
so it's how close are you to the neighbors,
your 40 acres?
Yes.
Um,
what do sounds you guys make and he freaks loans.
Alex Grey was actually just a gun nut you something to shoot.
This is all an act.
Well,
I love that.
One of your things from music,
you know,
like a sacred music.
We had a recent outdoor concert,
but there was also a fireworks display by the city that at,
by the town that night.
And so it was tiring.
It was perfect.
Yeah.
One of your things on your Kickstarter,
it's awesome.
There's only five left though,
but for $1,500,
you get a hand drawn portrait of you or your beloved the that's,
that's how awesome is that.
That's amazing.
I almost want to do that.
Wow.
That's so cool.
Yeah.
That's a good Kickstarter man.
Uh,
you,
you'll get some people definitely from this show and they get to it one more
time.
I feel like we're pvs.
Someone just say this one more time.
You know that those gross fucking PBS shows where every 15 minutes they would
chime in and try to get you to donate.
Like,
why don't you guys just get some commercial so you have to do this,
this disgusting.
Stop interrupting the conversation.
You're freaks.
Um,
so do you feel like you were already starting to have a gravity in this town?
It was,
and people are already starting to be drawn towards this,
this thing that you're creating.
And putting together with all these ceremonies and,
well,
we did have a recent event this past week and some of the,
it's call it,
well,
there was a recent event at the NT on this,
a new religion just moved in.
Recent of that's how they would describe a bunch of arrests.
Well,
here in La,
we actually had,
uh,
I,
I safe,
uh,
event,
where odd played and Ken Jordan from crystal method and a Ott.
He's a,
an amazing,
I kind of named after Jonathan Od.
But,
uh,
in terms of enough familiar,
who's Jonathan?
Jonathan Od is a translator of Albert Hoffman's.
And,
uh,
also was one of the people who,
came up with the term and theologian.
Oh,
okay.
With Dr. Hoffman,
a translator,
scientific translator.
Uh,
an author.
You said it was a translator of Hoffman's?
Yes.
What do you mean by a translator?
When a pro,
my problem child,
uh,
wanted to come out in English.
Uh,
you,
uh,
Albert Hoffman wanted someone who was responsible to his word and to his
meaning.
Oh,
I see.
Translate his words.
I'm so ignorant.
I wasn't aware that Albert Hoffman didn't speak English.
Yeah.
Now he was Swiss.
I figured if he's figured out how to make shit,
he's got to be American.
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
He spoke pretty good.
Good ish not to,
uh,
translate the book.
Wow.
That's fascinating stuff,
man.
Yeah.
So I played and,
uh,
Jonathan Singer,
who's a,
I call him a light slinger and a Vj Xtrordinair had made a printout of the
Pantheon,
um,
kind of altered Dj booth or I guess electronic musician station.
And uh,
so,
uh,
these wonderful musicians played,
behind something,
a console that looked a lot like the [inaudible] a thing.
So it printed it out.
And uh,
Ryan had made this a model for the booth and it was like a proof of concept of
this is how we're going to print out the building.
Right.
So it looks really cool.
Wow.
You're doing raves.
I think he got djs up there.
This is the best religion of all time.
Oh,
everybody's ecstatic.
Totally.
Yeah.
That's,
Oh yeah.
Got It.
Visionary,
you know,
that's,
that's a beautiful thing,
man.
And you're,
you know,
you're going to have a positive effect on a lot of people come through those
doors.
That's,
that's everything you would ever want out of a religion.
It was center where people can mean to community and the ability to push
something positive out those doors,
you know,
it's,
it's a beautiful thing,
man.
Totally is.
It's really about inspiring the creative spirit and in everybody,
you know,
and uh,
so that's ultimately why it's there.
And we also see that,
um,
in a dozen years or,
uh,
or 2020,
if possible,
uh,
if we're able to sort of pay back some of our loans and various things,
over the,
uh,
over time we look to build the actual chapel,
sacred mirrors in the meadow if possible.
And,
uh,
that,
if we're able to do that,
that we would move our arm out of the,
uh,
Antionne and have it as a sanctuary for visionary art from artists from around
the world,
um,
many of whom we've already come and done presentations there.
And,
and actually some of them are in the collection already and stuff.
So it will be a,
an active center for the promotion of this kind of new,
um,
art movement.
I'd say,
um,
that is worldwide and really is a product of this,
uh,
of seeing into these,
new dimensions.
I think you need your own podcast.
Absolutely.
Why not
a great way to reach people.
Super easy to do,
set up,
go to Libsyn.
You know,
you had an account not hard,
really easy to do and you could give people just a weekly updates on where
everything stands.
And I'm sure a lot of people would get into that.
And then,
you know,
and you could also have your thoughts on current events,
are your thoughts on,
you know,
whatever,
anything,
you know,
you don't have to be married to any particular amount of time.
Do it for 10 minutes if you like,
do a quick one just to keep everybody posted or do three hours,
do whatever the hell you want.
But,
but having something like that,
when you're doing something like this,
which is a very,
you're,
you're creating the center for community,
you're creating the center for sort of,
um,
the distribution of psychedelic ideas,
you know,
and in doing something like that and creating,
uh,
that kind of a community,
and I mean,
you really like putting a,
you're putting something out there into the world.
You're,
you're,
you're setting forth a beacon.
You know,
you're like,
you're,
there's going to be so many people that are influenced by that.
There's so many people that look at that and go,
well,
what is he doing?
What's going on over there?
And they've got full moons.
What does it big deal about four months?
What did these people doing?
Wow,
that's pretty,
what is this fucking building?
And then they get sucked.
Then.
Do you know you're doing that?
You're going to be comfortable as a cult leader or how's that?
That's at,
it's tough.
I think that's very tricky.
It's about,
uh,
as I said,
holding up a sacred mirror for people.
And,
uh,
if there's an element of inspiration in the,
for their own,
uh,
creative lives,
whatever it is,
then we can see that that's a spirituality that works for you.
You know,
because you have a creative life that has meaning for you.
So you're seeking to inspire other people to be more creative as well.
You see that start to spark transformation,
uh,
of the,
consciousness so that we can,
uh,
regard nature as a sacred ally that we need to learn from and to stop abusing
and that,
uh,
we can,
save what we can have the life web and,
uh,
have a humanity that lives for hundreds of thousands of years instead of snuffs
itself out in a stupid,
uh,
I,
oops,
I wreck the planet,
you know,
like I'm just a teenager,
what do you expect?
Um,
but you know,
like,
can we grow up?
Can we,
as a species,
it's,
I think it's the most exciting and amazing time cause it's like our Kickstarter,
I have a kind of a,
wow,
boy,
there's some gravity and the,
uh,
time line,
you know,
element.
Uh,
and,
uh,
of course,
we haven't got a United world that,
that at where we say collectively,
oh,
you know what,
that is too much carbon.
Uh,
let's do the sower.
Like really like hard,
you know,
and uh,
and so we can start to turn it around.
You know,
we're not,
we're not there yet,
but people in general I think,
feel that,
you know,
and they start to feel like the,
Oh wow,
how can we turn it around?
And,
uh,
so that's why I think that,
people like Paul Stamets and other visionary thinkers who understand more about
the,
uh,
intricacies and intelligence of,
say the fungus,
um,
that,
uh,
we have a lot to be hopeful about.
And,
uh,
if we put to use the technology and the intelligence that is already available,
you need to start a farm too.
You'd grow your own food out there.
Exactly.
Why not?
You've got 40 acres,
right?
It's a great area.
I'm sure it gets a lot of rain.
Well,
we're right next door to a great field and perhaps
it's an organic farm coming in.
So right now we're focusing on the temple,
but we,
all those things are part of the,
uh,
I think overall permaculture plan,
we're still mapping the land to see,
uh,
you know,
permit culturally what would make sense to develop.
That's going to be really fascinating and when it's done,
man,
I really can't wait and I'm,
I'm really excited about it.
But just goes to show you the negative thinking that some people just can't
escape.
Some people just can't help being negative no matter what.
I'm going to how positive someone else's messages.
Some people can't help being negative.
Somebody talked about your empathy and at the end that's what we're going to be
on.
Yeah,
they said it was a,
a shrine to your ego because you're creating a big piece of art,
big piece of beautiful art that somehow our shrine to your ego.
She's not a strange thing that people will accept art.
But if that art becomes a building that's then something's ego about it.
Like it can be the most beautiful thing as long as it's a painting or a
sculpture.
But when you make a house out of it,
then it's a shrine.
And it was a shrine to ego.
Like it can't just be a beautiful piece of art sculpture.
Why does someone have to hate like that?
That's,
that's gotta be the way you were raised.
It's gotta be the people that you're around.
There's no other way.
That kind of douchey thinking should be accepted.
Hey look,
uh,
everybody's entitled to their reaction.
And I think that it's inevitable that entitled to be mocked for their reaction.
People need to feel the sting of other people going,
bitch,
shut up.
What are you talking about?
The guy's making a beautiful building.
What are you,
what's your problem?
It's trying to,
his YG negative.
A lot of people need hugs.
That's what it is.
A lot of people didn't get them.
A lot of people need them now.
Well,
they,
they're very ideas.
The idea that there is,
uh,
basically one,
one face of God and it's all of us.
And,
and so,
uh,
there's a,
there's a multiple and then there's a one on the top of the roof.
So you got the one and the many and the many and the one.
And through consciousness evolution,
you can reach both.
And like,
I like that you say that and it doesn't sound goofy at all.
Do you know what I mean?
Like,
well,
the plain facts as you're sincere.
Wow.
But it's one of those concepts where you,
you know,
you start talking about the God is the one and the one of the Lord and you know,
and people go crazy fuck going on about your well Jeez.
You know,
okay.
You take it from a scientific perspective,
you know,
most are still on the big bang.
You know,
that 13.7 billion years ago,
there was nothing.
And then [inaudible] 13.7 billion years ago,
we're talking about it.
Right?
And so that was a lot of evolution.
That's a lot of development over a long period of time.
And,
and uh,
that's,
uh,
inherently the creative spirit brought us here and uh,
you know,
uh,
consciousness itself is,
is a miracle that we could understand each other.
It's fascinating.
Beyond fascinating,
but knows,
I love that you were optimistic too.
Like you,
you have hope for the human race.
Like I think there's no reason to be anything but because despite all the crazy
shit that's in the world of million nuclear weapons that can destroy every
single thing,
we haven't done it yet.
I mean,
it's kind of amazing.
It's kind of amazing that we've done as little pollution as we actually have.
I mean,
it's really quite shocking that we actually toned it down there.
That's a little bit of like,
hey,
everybody settled down.
You know,
like apparently the,
the pollution was much worse in Los Angeles,
like in the,
in the 60s and the 70s.
They said it was horrible because they have those led cars.
Like the gas was totally different and they'd cleaned that up a lot.
I mean,
it's still,
looks like shit.
It's still crazy brown air,
but it's better brown there Alex Gray.
Yeah,
it is.
That's a,
that's a symbol or the stage of evolution.
A bit of it.
Yeah,
a little bit.
And the,
the consciousness that was born during the 60s,
uh,
the civil rights era,
the,
uh,
feminism really came on strong.
The even eco consciousness,
all of these,
uh,
elements,
and,
uh,
gay rights.
Uh,
the,
the equality,
uh,
element started to come to the surface or a sense of conscience about,
accepting more diversity.
And,
uh,
you're living up to our,
idea about we,
the people you know,
and who are all the people.
And I think that the Rayanne Franchisement of,
uh,
people like just by saying,
okay,
gay marriages,
that's okay.
You know,
so then other nations say,
okay,
that's okay.
You know,
so suddenly a stigma,
uh,
and a prohibition on a group of people has been lifted and there Rayanne
franchised into,
uh,
the society at no harm,
to this society even benefit to it.
Likewise,
the cannabis user eventually,
I believe,
should be reintegrated into society and the world.
And this will show also an evolutionary step.
Um,
you know,
uh,
because,
this is the,
uh,
the recognition of the divinity of nature.
I think there's every reason to be optimistic and although there are some really
bad things about the world today,
financial system is crazy and corrupt and it's too easy to manipulate and
everybody knows it's rigged and we still have to use it and it's still the thing
that pays off lobbyists and moves decisions that favorite corporations instead
of the general public.
We still know that there's,
there's a lot wrong with the world,
but we're learning more about humans,
about behavior,
about just information itself,
about technology,
about our place in the universe.
We're learning more about the cosmos every day there's like some new discovery,
a new thing and new this and new that and it's just coming at us like like a
wave wave after wave of information.
I don't think it's possible to avoid all of that without some gigantic monsters.
Catastrophe.
I think if you just look at the,
if you were looking at a graph and you look at the head space of the American
person,
the average American person from 1960 and look at the headspace in 2013 where
was you're dealing with a completely different educated individual.
You are dealing with a level of understanding about the way the world works.
That's very different from at any other time because almost any question that
you've ever had can be answered on your phone within a matter of seconds.
And although that seems so normal,
that changed the whole world.
And that's going on right now.
I think it snuck up on us so fast.
We just get so used to watching movies on our phone that we don't even think
it's weird that it's just coming through the air into this little thin wafer
thing that's made out of glass and metal in your pocket,
that you get to watch movies flying through the air and you don't even think
about,
it just seems so normal to you and it's all psychedelic.
It's very much so,
and that's,
that's what,
uh,
I guess,
um,
Steve Jobs had to be interviewed by the Department of Defense and he had to
defend his taking of psychedelics and he said it's a,
yeah.
In order to get the highest clearance at and things.
So as a part of his interview,
he said that he still believed that it was,
uh,
one of the most important events in his life and,
that,
uh,
his psychedelic experiences.
And,
uh,
many of the people that they worked with,
of course,
uh,
they wondered how many times they had tripped and things and how far out are
you,
you know,
and,
uh,
was,
part of the openness to a new ways of thinking that,
uh,
it allowed just as you were saying that,
you,
after a psychedelic experience,
you have this folder that's called my old bullshit.
And then you have this possibility wide open in front of you.
Why,
my goodness,
a full new,
a new possibility there.
Uh,
you can jump back in the bag that you already know or you can forge ahead into a
new territory.
And so that's the evolutionary edge and you're always pushing it.
And artists and creative people are always pushing it.
And that's why I say everybody's kind of pushing that edge in some way and,
and is inherently that,
uh,
awareness.
Yeah,
I think it's unavoidable and it's almost that a biologically we couldn't keep up
with all the technological evolution,
although it's not the correct term to use technological evolution.
They want to use it biologically.
But that just,
that alone,
it's almost like our access to information is too great for our feeble minds to
process.
We're still on some,
you know,
old school pentium Celeron remember them?
Celeron one cries good as a pentium two.
Yeah.
I mean we're like on an old machine and machine sucks.
We have Dunbar's number.
We can't remember more than 150 people we fuck up.
Can't remember phone numbers anymore because you don't have to remember them
because they're on your phone,
you know?
So in that sense,
it's like we're almost becoming much,
it's almost like what the,
the technology is doing is setting us up.
It's getting us to a point where it's just overwhelming us with data that we
can't help that little bit.
I know you're having a problem.
Okay.
I'm going to help you out.
We'll get to give you a,
we're going to put this chip in your brain,
and once you do,
boom,
I mean,
the governor knows where you are at all times,
but you have instant 120 Iq.
You're going to be able to see things you never saw before,
memorize things fairly quickly.
It's a total brain upgrade.
So little chip of gps in there,
and there's a kill switch,
a fucking electrocution bolt into your brain.
If you say anything bad about the government,
there's movies,
uh,
being sort of made with that hypothesis.
I mean,
I think,
and the,
I always imagined the inf,
uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
interconnection,
of everyone,
uh,
being the ability to control the net and the vision.
Do you think at all about the technological singularity?
Do you follow Kurtzweil and all that?
Singularity?
Yeah.
Stuff.
I've,
I'm stuff it is fascinating.
And we have a friends,
uh,
Martine,
and uh,
uh,
Bina Rothblatt and a Martine,
and uh,
being,
uh,
have been working on a,
a robotic facsimile of Bina and,
um,
I'm interviewing that are you?
It's wonderful.
I'm interviewing her for my Scifi show.
I have realized,
yeah.
So her lover recreated exactly like my team.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
Yeah,
they're great.
They're wonderful people.
And uh,
uh,
we love them.
And uh,
yeah,
four children.
Yes.
And yeah,
that's,
that's amazing.
Yeah.
An artificial person or as close to it is what we have right now.
Right.
Well and,
and uh,
so I mean they're where the rubber meets the road.
They were really trying to push a program,
the robotics so that we can have a closer facsimile.
And of course,
you know,
under style.
Well,
the thing that,
that I found fascinating,
uh,
cause I,
I was very resistant to the whole idea and I love with a robot idea.
Well,
just the idea that the,
uh,
that the,
mmm.
That there will be a time when you will,
when this will be a problem.
You know,
that,
uh,
that you can not distinguish between a human being and a,
and a robot that's coming.
Don't you think?
I'm not sure.
Perhaps,
you know,
I'm naive to think that it isn't,
but I,
I,
but I have this feeling and just like,
uh,
people have,
a gay Dar or,
uh,
you know,
know each who's Jewish and who's not and things like that,
that eat that.
Having a,
uh,
that's a pretty,
it's subtle and intangible things know,
um,
to say that all body armor,
uh,
and uh,
you know,
like,
uh,
you know,
fact of your mechanical illness and inability,
uh,
you know,
to uh,
generate a subtle field even perhaps that's a heartbeat and a things,
these things are probably part of our unconscious awareness of a human being.
So,
uh,
I'll see,
you know,
as this,
as it develops,
you know,
artificial intelligence and robotics and things and I'm sure they'll,
part of it will evolve toward them.
I really feel like we're not giving technology the credit it deserves in that I
think it might be a lot.
And I know that sounds completely ridiculous because we were so sure that life
is like us.
We're so sure that life has cells and has blood and you know at either consumes
oxygen or it could be plant based life,
but we know what life is and that's not life.
No,
that's just something we created.
But no,
because eventually when you turn it on,
if it eventually gets to the point where he could reproduce on its own and think
for itself and defends itself or knows how to stay alive or has instincts or
knows how to repair itself,
then what exactly is that?
And it wa how come it's not as,
it's not life.
Why?
Because it doesn't have what?
This doesn't have skin.
Is it not?
Like if it's reproducing and thinking and altering its environment and then
moving forward and creating new energy sources and figuring out how to better
use resources.
If you've becomes intelligent life and some crazy asshole says,
you know,
and programs in,
hey,
defend yourself and reproduce as soon as you can.
Oh,
you're doomed.
The human race has done,
they're gonna.
You know,
for sure that's a life form.
That's,
it can be a life form and you're going to get to the point,
if this woman is recreating her wife,
it's going to get to a point where that's going to be indistinguishable.
There's going to be an artificial,
you there,
it might even be an artificial you.
That's exactly you.
It's your consciousness in another body.
You might be able to live several lives at once.
Syncytia fuck one of them up.
You've got a bunch of other good lives going on simultaneously.
You did the right to Benton Buddhist practices.
I think you can do that.
Anyway,
thanks.
So,
yeah,
but uh,
the,
uh,
the other,
element of the virtual,
uh,
haven't that I love that,
Martine and Bina talked about and they,
uh,
Terasem movement that they've been
putting forward as that,
uh,
we can,
program as much of the information about our lives and about,
um,
you know,
by filling out basically in an elaborate questionnaire.
And this also records,
uh,
our voice telling stories and things like that and the way that we inflect and
things.
So these modulations and things become part of,
uh,
what could be a virtual being.
It doesn't have to be a robot.
It can be,
um,
for the virtual heaven,
a just a facsimile,
a three d model that's based on the,
um,
sort of,
uh,
3-d,
um,
mapping of the head and,
uh,
maybe the,
the chest or something like that.
So you have a,
a sense of the person and you might ask a virtual grandma or Grandpa who passed
on several decades ago,
but the great grandkids can now access them via this virtual grandma,
uh,
that can say yes,
when I was growing up,
blah,
you know,
and share a story or something.
Now what's wrong with that?
What's wrong with that?
There's something crazy about turning grandma and grandma has a great beyond,
Oh,
so she was knitting.
Yes.
There's something fucking creepy about that.
Bad.
I mean,
maybe we need to let things go.
Maybe we need to realize that,
you know,
grandma's the past and whatever great memories that we had of her shower,
are you going to close her Facebook account?
You imagine if grandma's Facebook account becomes her.
Wow,
that's nuts.
God dammit.
But it's Kinda calm,
right?
I mean,
on Facebook a thousand years ago,
it seems to me that a blade runner type scenarios,
inevitable though where they have a life that is artificial but act so much like
us that it itself doesn't even know it's artificial.
Because if you're going to program a robot correctly,
to be a,
an artificial person that acts like a person,
you don't tell them and it's hard official,
you want them thinking they're real.
Right.
Of course.
Like it would be the blade runner scenario.
Yeah.
That was God damn brilliant movie.
It was,
it was shown
amazing.
But you know,
what it might mirror is this whole thing about the neanderthal and the,
and our early,
um,
relationship.
I as species we,
you know,
for thousands and thousands of years cohabited uh,
the same areas and what kind of a neanderthal genocide happened there,
you know,
like,
well,
what,
what was the shadow of our species,
you know,
built on this fire relationship.
Do you think they just naturally dark at all?
Oh No,
I think we definitely chilled them.
Did you ever see the people?
There's a one guy said it's a really sketchy theory,
but uh,
he painted in the end tall as like a gorilla faced Predator and uh,
he tried to say that Newton neanderthal probably hunted man and that's why we
drove it to extinction and that we based our image of what neanderthal looked
like based on human skin,
but we don't really have any skin from the inner towels.
We know that they were far stronger than people and we know that they had a much
thicker bone structure.
They were smaller,
they'd be like five feet tall,
but they would weigh 200 pounds.
They were really,
really incredibly strong.
Yeah.
Well they were more,
yeah,
more like a lower primate then like a human or a homosapien.
And so this guy,
see if he could pull that up,
Brian.
It was pretty trippy.
It's mostly bullshit,
but it's Kinda fun bullshit.
This guy,
um,
fuck w what would you say?
Um,
neander tall predator.
Yeah.
See if you find that.
And he had like a whole video where they mapped out,
uh,
in his opinion what it would look like in a three d imagery.
And so we had this really scary looking chimpanzee thing.
Big giant eyes.
We don't have any eye tissue from the intercalls either.
And they have a much larger eyeball humans.
Yeah,
they're bought it.
They're just,
they're built fairly differently.
So this guy true them up like crazy gorilla monsters.
It's really,
I mean,
I don't think it's right,
but it's a,
it's kind of cool to look at and it's interesting just to conceive of it is wow.
That's how he drew it.
He drew it like they might've been Harry and they might've been like,
what?
They were really muscular and he made them look more chimpanzee like then,
uh,
then human like,
yeah.
Huh.
Yeah.
He did a whole documentary on it.
I think it's probably bullshit.
Well,
you know,
you could genetically imagine you're yourself into a Sasquatch.
I was going to ask you,
I've been hunting for south Crotch,
not hunting,
like trying to hurt him.
Like,
look,
I should say searching for Sasquatch.
I've been doing this TV show.
We went up to Washington state and uh,
we stayed in the woods out near Mount Rainier and uh,
it's like a tropical rain.
I mean not tropical,
a rain up there,
real rain forest.
Like if you've never been up there,
you've no idea what that's like.
It's the weirdest environment ever.
You Park your car,
you take a walk you a hundred yards into the woods and you might as well be on
another planet.
You are,
you're literally enter into a different dimension.
There's the dimension of,
of there's a dimension of highways and houses and that's all out there.
But once you go into a rain forest,
like you just,
you go a little bit in and then you're engulfed by this new reality and this
reality,
as you see an elk running past you and they disappear in the trees cause
everything is so thick and,
and people start to see pig foot,
you know,
they start seeing anything,
man,
you know what the fuck is out there?
You think big foot's preposterous until you go to a rain forest,
like the Pacific northwest and you're walking around and you're like,
fuck,
maybe man.
Yeah,
yeah.
Quiet eight now.
But if you look at the earliest,
um,
kind of human animal,
hybrid cave art,
yeah.
You have something that looks oddly like a Sasquatch type,
uh,
thing,
you
know,
because it's,
it's just a marriage of the stag and the human,
and so it's got characteristics of the animal and the human together.
They didn't love that stuff really early on.
Yes.
Well,
look at all the Egyptian art,
you know,
it's Paul.
What do you think that is?
The fusion of the creature,
the animal,
the theory and Morph,
uh,
it's called theory and morph.
That's a term for it.
Isn't that what those furies call themselves too?
They call themselves therians.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I think that that's a,
probably a,
not that there's anything wrong with being a furry and much love.
My mascot friends,
I accidentally stumbled into a furry conventional once in Pittsburgh.
It was,
you know what?
It's going to sound stupid,
but I thought it was beautiful.
I thought it was beautiful that these people found a place where they could all
get together and do this.
The obviously they liked doing it,
they liked doing it.
And where,
you know,
if you do that in your neighborhood,
people going,
what the fuck are you doing man?
Why are you dressed up like a giant chipmunk?
But for whatever reason,
I don't know why they liked doing it,
but it doesn't seem like they're hurting anybody.
And we were walking,
they seem so happy.
But walking down the street and all these,
these fairy dudes and gals were laughing and talking together all with their
crazy costumes on and nobody took the shit off.
And I was like,
this is the weirdest thing ever.
But it looks so fun.
It's embodying our kind of doctors shoes.
So like,
uh,
zany truth about the world of creatures that we're a part of and it's
acknowledging that we're part of,
uh,
I,
almost,
uh,
interdimensional um,
and web of creatures.
And I think that the early stuff,
the Egyptian and all,
all the cave art and things like that really does,
did come out of a place of higher awareness that that was the kind of a nature
[inaudible]
just citizen.
Well,
like a lot of seconds,
the psychedelic drugs have animal ideas in embedded in them.
And I'm absolutely,
especially with DMT or Iowasca,
there's the jaguars are leopards,
jaguars,
right?
Jaguars and snakes and,
yeah.
And those sort of things.
I mean,
I'd only kind of make sense place.
Absolutely.
Or maybe it could have been many different psychedelic compounds we don't even
know about anymore that these people would found and that,
that put him them together with these,
these ideas.
And I've combining animals and human into one form.
Yes.
Well,
it's a,
an,
an easy transfer.
And the thing that I found
refreshing in the Egyptian temples and things was,
uh,
how easy it was to transpose a head and a staff of one creature and another onto
a human body and how I,
they were considered the gods.
Now if your job is to,
uh,
sacred eyes,
the nature field,
uh,
to give a sense of,
the place that we live in is a,
is a gift of the,
of a divine creator.
And there are,
uh,
then if you're gods actually are different animals or they have animal
characteristics,
more,
you're more apt to treat the animal with some respect or as being an aspect of
that divinity.
And so the,
uh,
the translation of the,
the archetypal symbol of a particular animal spirit and a divine human form is
to acknowledge our oneness with that kind of,
uh,
the field of,
of the animal spirits.
And it's a very shamonic,
uh,
kind of thing to do.
And it,
and it was part of many of the,
uh,
like the Mesopotamian Babylonian,
Assyrian,
Egyptian,
uh,
even the Greeks sphinxes and things like that.
There's,
uh,
there's this,
fusion from the very earliest cave art all the way through the great religious
kinds of things.
Angels have wings there,
animal and human hive.
That's a really good,
you know,
I never even thought of until just now that it's still part of the public
imagination,
you know,
and uh,
we,
it's crazy angels apart bird.
I just thought there were people with wings,
but no,
obviously not.
Well,
if they had a bird's head,
then you'd be like,
they're part bird.
But as long as they have a human side,
you like not even a bird man in jail.
Yeah,
Carson so much
because we,
uh,
the,
the idea of there being a higher world that we ascend to symbolically,
it's so transparent that we don't even notice it.
It's just like there and,
uh,
I think that that archetype is part of the human psyche and you can find it in
each,
you know,
sacred path.
They,
the,
uh,
the bridging of the realm.
So that's twice the Hermes was Hermes Trismus justice,
you know,
the occult,
uh,
kind of,
um,
the foundation.
I bumped Dinesh.
Yeah.
You know,
so many versions of the combining of a human and an animal and sacred religious,
uh,
artwork.
It's really fascinating.
I'll get the Hindi stuff.
Whereas a man with a lion's head and people have it like octopus arms,
six arms.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
All a bunch of people trying to make sense of what they're experiencing,
Soma or whatever it is.
Eight Sam.
Uh,
well,
it's very interesting.
Uh,
I think so.
For most people,
you're thing,
since cannabis,
most people are like,
it's a sleeping pill.
[inaudible] what are you talking about?
They don't know.
Like some of the sleeping pill is,
they've fucked up.
They should never named it the Soma Soma's like it's,
it's,
it's a sacred psychedelic drug from,
was it,
was it from the Rig Veda?
Uh,
6,000 years ago.
The earliest,
uh,
human,
um,
you know,
probably just text is the songs.
Uh,
uh,
in the rig Veda,
they Hindu text
and some assholes on the wall and turned that into a sleeping pill.
Pharmaceutical sleeping pill.
What?
A bunch of dicks.
Wow.
There you go.
I mean,
that's like really rude.
You know,
that's like Catholics would never take that.
If you had a,
a sleeping pill that was called the sacrament,
that Jesus sacrament,
they'd be like,
Hey,
fuck head.
You can't call it that,
but people are like Soma.
Yeah.
That's in another country.
And we're America and we're gonna just going to call it [inaudible] cause we
liked the name Soma.
It is okay.
Soma.
Yeah.
But the original Soma was supposed to be an amazing,
right,
exactly.
And it put,
uh,
the,
person who imbibed it into a state of connectedness with the divine.
And,
uh,
someone was also the s it was recognized as the source of many things,
including like clothing and stuff like that.
As an artist.
Why do you think that you were the first person to really encapsulate the trip?
To me,
an experience cause all these other people that didn't have these amazing works
of art.
The only people that can't close to capturing the trip.
To me an experience to me where the ancient Egyptians,
there's a lot of ancient Egyptian stuff like just to Don Commons,
a head dress and the gold,
the gold that's varied.
Tryptamine like,
you know,
and he's one of the only things in,
um,
in historical art to me that rings and rings trippy.
You know,
there's something about it like you,
like you can almost to like hear music don't get good,
like some kind of trip to me in music when you're watching these hieroglyphs and
he's seeing these images,
you're like the symbols.
Like even if you don't understand what they mean when you're looking at these
symbols run together,
your mind starts to try to form patterns and you start to try to think the way
these people were thinking and see these incredibly complex geometric shapes
that they had turned into buildings,
buildings like the temple and man,
this gigantic building where each segment represents different shock rose and
different energy points in the human body.
There's texts around each one explaining this part of the human body.
Like it's,
it's fucking insane.
Yes.
We want to bring that idea to the land of Kozum and uh,
have been,
uh,
you know,
the idea,
uh,
of these,
the Neta row of the family of Gods in Egypt is a really made a strong,
um,
what isn't it,
uh,
imprint on me.
When we went over there,
and Alison and I have been back a couple of times,
it called against the net,
or rue is the family of gods that,
uh,
kind of opened up out of newt,
the night sky,
who had an affair with Gab,
the,
uh,
earth father.
So the night sky mother,
uh,
held five,
children in her womb and had defined a special time,
uh,
to,
release them.
But the one,
uh,
who,
was in there with his brothers and sisters decided he didn't want to stick
around.
He was the dark kind of Lord and his name was set and he cut his way out of his
mother and,
uh,
out tumbled the rest of the brothers and sisters,
including a thougth and Isis and Osiris and,
uh,
net Thiess his sister.
So,
uh,
basically isis in ocirus got together and they were the,
you know,
football hero and the cheerleader,
uh,
you know,
match made in heaven and all that.
And they were,
uh,
they were,
you know,
just like,
uh,
celebrated and stuff and set was kind of a barren,
you know,
and,
and he was kind of a,
you know,
just probably a little jealous of his brother maybe.
And a net Thies,
uh,
wanted a child.
And,
uh,
so anyway,
she,
uh,
fooled Oh,
crs into an affair,
uh,
perhaps in new a new bus.
Uh,
the dog headed,
uh,
embalmer,
of the Nether worlds was the result of that.
Well,
of course set was extremely disturbed and,
uh,
decided that he was going to find a way to kill ocirus,
which eventually happened and he cut him up and threw them all over,
uh,
denial.
And so isis was extremely distraught and she went around finding,
uh,
or remembering parts of the dismembered God and each place where she found a
hand or a flood or something like that at temple was built.
And so you would,
you would go down the Nile,
uh,
and,
remember the God and that's,
that's the idea is just,
uh,
the,
now I think that it,
of course,
it's the goddess that's been lost.
That's been a dismembered,
the,
the mother earth.
And uh,
so the idea is to,
uh,
we have different stations on the land where there'll be a foot,
there'll be hand and different things like that.
They'll represent different elements
of the dismembered a mother.
So we go around to remember,
uh,
the,
the mother and to re new ourselves and to read new nature.
Trying to wrap your mind around Egyptian mythology and what they were,
what they meant by that and the origin of that and how it led them to the
society that was able to create those insane structures.
They're amazing.
I've haven't been,
I've,
I've the only really crazy place I've been to his teaching eatsa.
Oh,
did cheat.
You need,
so once,
that was one of those things where you're walking around going,
how did the,
what are they doing?
Well,
how did they do this?
Why they do this?
Yeah.
This is crazy.
And no one lived here anymore.
They just all moved out.
They made this and then they left.
Somebody left behind this.
Yeah.
And you and people return there.
You returned there.
We returned there.
Nobody there is there.
No,
we,
funny if some dude said this is my house now put a door in one of the top bulls.
Sometimes there are caretakers,
a t for these sacred sites.
And uh,
so if they're heard,
hadn't believes right,
they just mowed down.
One of the,
uh,
ancient Mayan temples are pyramids that was there.
It's like a really,
really old structure.
Oh,
I tend to the plotted down cause it was on private land just to use it for
limestone.
Good Crane.
Yeah.
People are freaking out.
Like,
what the fuck did you do?
Well,
you know,
there's,
there's a different feelings in the different societies about these things.
You know,
the Taliban just destroyed a huge,
uh,
a Buddhist sculpture,
which was a heritage type site that I had had been there for thousands of years
and probably the CIA pretending to be to tell.
But look what they did.
These fucks,
I didn't say that.
I didn't mean it
back.
Well,
I had to know at least that was the story that got out and it,
and it was sad,
but it was still most likely true.
I mean,
religious ideologies.
But gets people to do almost every really fucking crazy,
like it's either money or religious ideology,
you know,
or we ideology in general negative ideology,
like we were talking about,
the Boston bombings were like,
you can't do that without ideology.
Like no one is able to do something like that without ideology because you have
to have something that allows you to think that that's the correct thing to do
and your ideology of hate.
Not all ideologies are bad,
but you don't,
you don't get really insane acts of faith like that without an ideology.
Right.
Insane acts of terrorism either.
Both things come from,
you know,
it's not always bad,
but it's tricky.
It's tricky when you just automatically subscribed to the patterns that are in
front of you.
We'd like be,
we like to be in patent.
It's like getting to that mild bullshit thing on the desktop.
We felt really comfortable,
like going down already tread paths.
Yes,
it's really true.
And it's sad,
uh,
that the,
the,
the more wide spread understanding of jihad as a holy war,
um,
within the Muslim community is that it's something that they ego wages.
Um,
you know,
uh,
we,
we engage with our ego basically somehow the soul and the ego is always in a
kind of a holy war with each other that,
uh,
that we desired the one true spirit to win out and to,
to have love saved the day and all these things to be a hero in life.
And,
uh,
this is,
I think part of why we're called to a call to life.
Okay.
Well the,
the,
the original term was supposed to be like a Wark and see your own vices,
right?
Personal vices.
Yeah.
I'm a better person.
And,
and it's a struggle to become a better person in the same way that a Ecri,
Israel means God wrestler,
you know,
where we're struggling with this higher nature and,
uh,
without engaging it somehow,
without struggling with it and to,
uh,
be,
activated in our,
uh,
creative pursuit of it.
Um,
it's not,
it's not real or tangible for us.
It has to become a real,
uh,
practice.
That's why like any kind of art or creativity or any,
any form of expression,
uh,
cause that's what we're made of or made of creative energy.
Yeah.
That's what we're here for.
We have,
what is the,
was it,
um,
Marshall Mcluhan said that human beings are the sex organs of the machine world.
Huh?
That's what we're doing.
We're just,
uh,
we're just creating little computer babies.
That's how computers get made.
People create them.
That's true.
It's a new form of intelligence that were living amongst,
are you going to download your consciousness into a computer when the time
comes?
We'll have to see what's available.
You know,
uh,
I love Martine's,
response.
Cause I was saying,
right,
well,
hey,
you know,
I don't know about a soul in a robot and stuff like that.
But she was,
it was saying like,
well who's to say that a soul,
if there were a disembodied spirit wouldn't like hanging around a,
a robot of itself,
uh,
for
awhile or who's to say you're not going to create a Zombie in the next dimension
of the person's going to be born without a soul.
Cause he put it in somebody fucking computer.
And so then
all of a sudden the next dimension is like the dotted debt.
You've got a bunch of zombies running around.
That could happen.
Maybe that's the Zombie apocalypse,
apocalypse.
Maybe that's where now we've seen the walking dead and this sort of thing.
This Zombie theme keeps returning over and over and over again.
That's a warning telling us not to download our consciousness to computers.
We already have.
You know,
that's,
that's what Facebook is.
That's my space,
right?
Yeah.
Our town
where our Instagram or on Twitter,
all of these things are a virtual existence and uh,
you know,
Wiki and various things like this.
They,
they give people maybe a sense of solidity.
No,
that's why it's weird to go to someone's Twitter page after they're dead.
Have you ever done that before?
No,
but I'm page.
I have a friend who,
a really great guy who a expired and every now and then I go to his Facebook
page and I'll read his posts and go,
you know,
I keep reading this post.
I'm still getting a little bit of him.
You know,
you watch a video of him getting a little bit of him,
you know,
it's not new stuff.
I listened to ray man's Eric today.
He died today.
Yeah.
But I listened to him.
He was like 72.
Right?
Isn't that crazy?
Then the doors,
he was in the doors and he's 72.
It's like,
wait a minute.
Warm the dirt going on.
How old are we getting Jesus?
While there's something timeless within that,
he downloaded himself into a computer right before we kicked off,
I think into all of our consciousness and uh,
and the computers are just a,
uh,
the external storage devices.
What's really the cool thing is that we're connected with all of it.
Just consciousness wise.
What do you think the next stage of consciousness is going to be?
Do you think it's going to be some sort of,
uh,
an ability to read each other's minds,
to integrate with each other,
to exchange information freely through the air?
Like a Wifi signal?
What do you think it's going away?
I,
all of that.
All that it's coming right?
Can't stop it.
I think that it's a,
an inevitable,
um,
evolutionary development.
However,
uh,
some of it's going to take training and some of it's going to take an
orientation toward it and an opening up,
uh,
a ideas of,
clairvoyants and,
uh,
extra sensory perception and things like that,
can,
uh,
be trained,
in some,
uh,
to be enhanced.
I have a completely uneducated faith in the fact that people far smarter than me
are going to continue to do awesome work.
I'm,
I'm convinced that they're going to continue to come out of school and figure
new things out,
even though I am not placing.
I'm,
I'm like,
wow,
we're really coming up.
What's really fast computers?
I'm not coming up with shit,
but somewhere,
some,
I,
I'm convinced they're going to continue to do awesome stuff.
So whoever you are out there,
keep it up.
Congratulations and thanks indeed.
Thank you so much.
Well,
thank you Alex Grey.
And uh,
please,
uh,
go to Alex gray.com g r e y.com.
And um,
and please participate in the Kickstarter.
It's your chance to be a part of something really cool.
Like,
uh,
beautiful building that's going to have a beautiful cause.
It's going to have a beautiful movement behind it and you're already doing
amazing things.
And I swear to God,
if I lived up there,
I'd be visiting all the time.
Even when the shit hits the fan,
I moved to the Hudson Valley.
It's cool up there,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's cold in the winter though.
No.
Yeah.
If you ever make it northeast,
we'd love to.
How far is it from New York City?
It's a car drive about a hour and a half.
Oh,
that's nothing.
that's great.
You know,
it's also a metro north.
You can take the,
uh,
from grand central.
You can walk from the station there.
I would love to come check it out and I absolutely want to come once it's all
done just to see how crazy it's kind of,
maybe you can help us kick it off.
Yeah,
for sure.
let's,
let's do some sort of a party or something.
Yeah.
But all Tracy hippies out there,
keep it together.
Don't get to 90 at this party.
You know,
Alex,
great to cast.
And it changed him.
So I'm going to take it all.
No,
not at the party.
Find a nice peaceful,
quiet spot in the woods.
Find Nice spot in the woods.
So it's Alex grey.com.
Is there any,
and I'm on Twitter.
Your Twitter is,
uh,
Alex grey Kozum Cos and so please follow him on Twitter.
Alex.
Great.
Cause I'm right now you got 22,511.
Let's see if we could boost that shit up to 22,600 PBS again,
I went PBS again.
I Apologize Ladies and gentlemen please.
But the support,
this,
it's an awesome cause if you've got the cash,
if you don't,
you know,
don't do it.
Um,
thank you everybody for tuning in.
We really appreciate it.
Thanks everybody.
Uh,
who's been,
uh,
coming out to these shows and all the cool people that I met when I was looking
for bigfoot.
Great fucking time.
Um,
we'll be back on Thursday with the Great Graham Hancock.
He'll be joining us thanks to Ting for sponsoring our podcasts.
Go to rogan.ting.com and save 25 bucks.
You Freak.
Um,
thanks to Squarespace,
squarespace.com,
forward slash Joe.
And if you want to use it,
use the offer code Joe Five.
Uh,
thanks also to onnit.com Code A.
O.
N.
I.
T.
Use the code name rogue and save some money.
God Damn,
I gotta record that shit cause it sounds so repetitive.
I'm broken.
I can't say it anymore.
All right,
we love you guys and we'll see you on Thursday.
Thank you very much.
Bye Bye.